I need to say a quick piss all right do
something funny for the patreon man no
no all right welcome back to another
episode of trash taste today I'm joined
by the boys G Joe as usual and today
very special guest the man the myth the
legend Mudan himself the editor
hello are are you going to put the
little Mudan in people don't know this
actually I think the Casual viewers
don't know that you've put a mini Mudan
in every single trash episode from which
episode I think from episode 18 onwards
there's a little bit of you and it's
really hard to fine yeah it's like a
where's Waldo or where's Wally of like
people found some of them though oh yeah
I found some of them after a while I
started to make it a bit easier so when
people check they'll find it easier then
I hard made it it harder again yeah so
our editor is visiting us here in Japan
and uh we thought let's just uh get him
on the podcast and expose him or let him
expose us I don't know which way it's
going to be today I think it's
definitely the him exposing yeah
definitely yeah so how have you found
Japan it's been better and also a bit
worse than I expected right cuz is this
your first time yeah it's my first
timeit so you're from Estonia uh and so
first first time in Asia right yeah oh
wow I'm in Asia damn I mean I when I
left it was 16° c yeah so when I arrived
here it was like
like got the tail end of the he people
said it was so much worse before and I
was like what yeah it was what do you
mean it was Yeah Yeah so basically if
you don't know Mudan is basically the
reason most of us here uh exist Mudan is
the reason why exists basically yeah so
m m edits this podcast M also edits all
of my most of my channels yeah yeah all
of them off with all of them yeah yeah
and then Joey's uh main Channel as well
and uh who else do we edit for uh Sydney
Ary um some people I don't know if I
should
mention okay uh like 10 different people
right now Jesus 10 different people as
well now as well hell damn basically I
think I might only my channels are Prett
free to preface this is not you doing
this so no yeah yeah I got a very
dedicated team behind me who are
probably more talented than me so how so
how many so you kind of built like um
like your own I guess like editing
company was it or like organization when
the [__] did that start cuz yeah cuz I
think I came in when you were just
editing for trash taste I was like oh
mud's anything everything and then he
started from Conner and then started for
Sydney and then Conner launch second
Channel and I'm like how is Mudan
keeping up with all this when uh when
did it happen yeah so I wanted to do
video editing as a full-time job and it
took like a long time to get off I was
do like barely earning any money for the
first two years but then suddenly I
guess through recommendations people
were like oh he's doing a good job let
me recommend him to another person and
finally I had like three people I think
you and Connor and somebody else and it
was like sometimes it was easy cuz it
was like one video a week but sometimes
you'd be like like oh I'm going to
America for a month here are four videos
that need to be done right and it would
like accumulate together with you guys
so I was like okay I cannot keep on
working $300 a month so I was like okay
let me find somebody else and thankfully
uh my first another editor was uh Danny
dedor uh he I found him through a mutual
and pretty much it took like six months
to teach him up but he's like a
right-hand man R really talented and uh
then like half a year later both of us
were doing 300 hour
work
months so how it works like that huh
yeah and then I realized okay we need to
keep on expanding so now I have a huge
team behind me I think in Estonia like
in my own company I have Danny I have
mudam who's uh my partner as well yeah
there's another Mudan
mudam so you're Mudan and there's also
mudam yeah okay like a female
Mudan
mudam so I mean she actually lates does
the trash taste like um scene changes oh
she's she's also a professional camera
operator in Estonia like uh Sports
shoots and stuff oh cool so she has
background in it so how many people do
you have now like in your company I have
four who I've hired like in my company
per se which means I pay like for their
holidays for for health and stuff and
around 10 Freelancers plus minus four
God damn it's cool that you've gone from
just being solo to that yeah also kind
of crazy to have that kind of ambition I
think a lot of people would be like okay
this is this is scary yeah it is it is
horrible every day I wake up and sweat
I'm like oh my God is this the downfall
today yeah cuz I was going to ask uh you
are human right you I just I just want
to check that you've not you're you want
see if I you know like the T 100 like
well you're wearing you're wearing a
wristband that checks your vital so I'm
not too sure
if you don't know like Mudan or like you
are the most efficient human being I've
ever met in my life to the point where
sometimes I question if you have not
like pre-programmed yourself every
morning to be the most efficient thing
you could be I remember one one uh time
where I was like yeah this guy's not
human was uh it was ax a few years ago
where you were there and we were just
chilling out in the hotel room um or the
hotel lobby or something and we were
just like chatting and all that kind of
stuff and then just like as this
conversation is going between Mudan
myself and like a couple of other people
Mudan just like pulls his phone out and
just starts like doing something and I
thought you were like playing a game and
I looked over and you had mirrored your
computer back at home onto your mobile
and you were editing a video on your
phone yeah I think it was because trash
tase like M needed uh the outro
cinematic to be like longer or something
yeah and it had to be done within half
an hour you were just doing it on your
phone not human it takes a while it's
like 10 times longer on the phone but
it's [__] it's 10 times longer yeah so
like I I want to ask what is your advice
for like efficiency hack how how does
how does how do you how did you minmax
your life yeah how do you minmax your
life as much as possible addiction just
be addicted to one thing do it just
stick to that that's the only
explanation I think a lot of a lot of
the times when um people have uh where
YouTubers and they work with editors
it's kind of like this honeymoon period
where it's really fun and it's exciting
to edit for for someone new and then it
kind of you know becomes a lot more like
okay there's a deadline can we make sure
we meet it and it becomes like that but
I guess yeah you it's never been like
that for you which is so how did you I
guess that's one thing I've always
wanted to ask you is like how did you
get into like video editing like where
where does that passion come from well
uh I don't know about a lot of people
but pretty much until I was like 17 16 I
had no ambition in life like I didn't
know what I want to do you just
described every teenager exactly people
ask you oh what do you want to be when
you grow up you're like it worker I
don't [__] know yeah uh but well when
I was 13 I was really like panic mode
looked around my room like what what
should my purpose in life be show my PSP
I saw my PSB collection was like I'm
going to collect all of them okay and
that was for the next 5 years that was
my life's purpose right and then I think
in high school they had like um uh
cameras at school mhm and I borrow them
for like uh ex no actually just before
that year I decided to do like um a stop
motion
Tetris in with chocolate for some reason
I don't know why kind of c c yeah cuz
like back then the cameras didn't really
shoot film like none of the phones had
videos and I had one camera at home and
it was like one of those old ones that
only shot pictures so I couldn't like
shoot video I was like all right stop
motion it is and when I got to school
they actually had cameras you could
borrow so I got to I borrowed the camera
and it was really fun to like think of
something and make it into a reality and
then for the next three years I pretty
much had the camera like half the time
with me D [__] hell so like we talked
about this before we started recording
but what are you wearing now
like yeah cuz I thought it like me and
Conor thought it was a wristwatch at
first and I was like wait a minute I
can't see any numbers on that no this is
a this is a whoop this is uh pretty much
to uh check your uh vitals I guess like
what is a better word to use it we have
it's like dystopian as [__] to say that
you have the same thing you just have a
screen on it it's just steps it's steps
doesn't it check your pulse uh yeah it
does too yeah does it check your sleep
uh I don't wear it for bed it does the
same thing I just don't have a how the
[__] can you sleep how can you sleep
with it on I don't know I mean I mean
there is there is something ironic about
me being like Oh Yeah it's you're so
distopian ha wow I I I was uh thinking
of getting like a smart watch and then I
was like I don't want a screen on my
watch so this was the most the time if I
get buzzed like three times in a row too
fast I just like rip it off I'm like
[__] this I'm like I'm like stop pissing
me off I used to wear a smartwatch as
well but like just the constant like cuz
every notification goes to your wrist
right so it's like I don't want this I
just liked it when I it was just kind of
s extra catarium even though you don't
need this when you go to the gym or you
work out or even if you do a long walk
and you come back it's like that walk
was 700 calories like damn nice but how
true is it uh probably not true it's
probably a little over generous uh but
this one has the fit it's [__]
anyway it's all [__] yeah so I mean
like this is this is going to something
different now but so you wanted a smart
watch that wasn't a smartwatch but that
could give you everything that a
smartwatch could give you except for
telling the time yeah well are you are
you trying to optimize being a human
yeah what do you mean okay he's trying
to fit in with the
humans like are you trying are you
trying are you trying to become the
perfect human being so to edit better
you need to be healthy oh my God [__]
hell mud if you're tired the day is
going to go to waste you can't get as
much done so you need to be more
productive you need to sleep well you
need to eat well you need to get all
your vitamins are you being like very
health conscious recently yeah not like
maximizing everything like 100% but just
a bit more I saw you made a tweet saying
like you what happens if you take like
any every vitamin on Earth was that like
a joke tweet or is that something you've
done I'm taking it it's still here what
the f i i i i we shared a room not too
long ago and uh he had this like Monday
Tuesday can I can I say this he had this
Monday Tuesday Wednesday medicine thing
he had two of them and they were both
full of just various pills and I was
like there was at least 20 pills a day
he was taking you're not human bro and
what were you what what is they like
what are you taking 24 okay 24 pills
what is what is yes and it's like a
handful like a legit handful of pills
it's nice it's like your morning lunch
as well dude you get
what so what is of calories okay what is
what is in these 24 pills and what are
you hoping to get out of it okay so it's
uh basic vitamins in Estonia you lack
Sunshine a lot so I was like vitamin D
deficient so that's a big thing then I
have minerals like I was also cuz Okay
how do you know if you're vitamin D
deficient okay first of all don't take
pills just cuz you can buy them like I I
it sounds like when you're 24 pills you
got to be close no I did a different
blood test to like first of all vitamin
tests and then mineral tests yeah cuz I
mean vitamin D deficien is pretty bad
okay where did you get this done how did
you this is a place you can do it yeah
maybe I should do it going to go I got
to go to the hospital and they give you
like blood grades and stuff yeah yeah
but it's not about like vitamins and
stuff and minerals it's just about like
blood Health whatever that means
whatever that means like a long time ago
uh because I didn't eat red meat that
much cuz I just didn't want to uh I was
very vitamin B12 like deficient and I
would get like insane headaches and
tired and I didn't know why and then I
took the pills and I was like fine like
2 weeks
afterward I mean it sounds smart when
you put it in that perspective but also
it sounds kind of bizarre bro you're
going to end up in the [__] like old
folks with like
80 what is it only red meat where you
can get that vitamin or was there some
kind of food youed for like red meat is
the best like thing for you didn't want
to just change the diet a little bit you
want to cuz I was kind of dumb like
every day I would eat the same things I
would wake up eat porridge in the middle
of day I'd eat pasta at night I eat rice
with like chicken and that was all carvs
that's what all I eat for like 2 years
straight like only those things yeah I
think I'd get a headache too if I at all
for two years it was fine I liked it I'm
sure you did but like wait what was the
pest are you pling or like something I I
had some uh cheese on it I can see why
you wear the whoop now
bro do you know how expensive is i' be
pretty scared as well for my vitals it
was really cheap it was like 50 bucks a
month on was was this before you became
a fulltime editor actually know that
checks out you just do I need be paying
you more like are you good like no when
I got uh when I got actual job I was
like all right in my poast I'm going to
put like minced meat now I'm
moving living good okay honey we're
eating good tonight we're putting M Meat
in this so personal question have you
always been like conscious about how
optimized you are as a human being or
was this something that happened
naturally as you got more editing jobs
and you kind of like started working
more uh for all of us I'm asking if we
if why you look at me like like I was
you were like like preparing for to say
something I was like I was thinking I
was like yeah I think I do optimize
something things but not like my dietr
or which I probably should optimize I I
definitely think about I I do you anyone
do you anyone do this where you when I
need to do multiple things in the house
I'm always constantly thinking about the
optimal path in order to do everything
and I'm obsessed with it I don't know
why but the problem is is that for a lot
of people they think about the optimal
path but they think about it for way too
long and then don't get any of it done
just happened that just happened sorry
go ahead oh uh what was the question
yeah so like were you always conscious
about how optimize your life was uh kind
of it it mostly depends on how like
where I am in life cuz like people can
watch YouTube videos like oh how to
optimize your life and like it's like 10
things but that doesn't work cuz you
need to optimize it for yourself
everybody is so different it's not
personalized so even if I find like a
perfect app that works me for that year
like two years later I might move to
something that works for that time in
the beginning when I didn't have like a
team I didn't need Google Calendar I
didn't need like specific apps but now
that it's like bigger or my life is
different I like change it around yeah
so when did the vitamins like at which
point because okay I understand 24
[__] vitamins so when when does the
vitamin AR start so I understand like
optimizing your life getting calendars
getting like a to-do list every day you
know I've done that uh there's a there's
like there's a big step for me from like
trying to optimize some parts of you
life to be like I can take every vitamin
Under the Sun to make sure that my body
is as optimized as possible which you
know is actually a pretty smart thing to
do to become health conscious but that
is a big step I just don't want to be on
a steady diet of pills you know I mean I
assume any of the people who do this are
like professional actors who have to get
in like crazy shape or something right
like they have like the most insane body
coaches it's not like it's insane I
don't know testosterone pills or
something it's like very basic stuff
like What vitamin b c d uh [__]
magnesium calcium selenium you know
you're not getting any of this stuff
enough not really you need to be
expanding maybe your like Diet I mean I
no I think I think we probably have
deficiencies too but I'm just like oh
man feel tired today I'll just tomorrow
be be fine CH a couple of coffees and we
good you know like half a year ago I
stumbled upon this YouTuber I was
influenced okay okay okay called like
Brian Johnson who who looked like kind
of like kind of insane cuz he's like
this kind of a vampire insane rich
person who tries to live forever in a
way I was very skeptical in the
beginning but then
he
motives that he does TS his for free 100
and I was like okay that's pretty
interesting and I looked at his
statistics and all the pills and
everything and uh like his description
and how he changed his life and I was
like okay well I'm going to try it out
for a month see how it works and after
like 2 weeks my I would say my personal
like feelings increased by like 20% my
wellbeing a sizable change I'm should
try this too and I'll come back uh and
be like man you changed my life yeah
Conor's going to come back to the office
with a med some box I got I got to
figure out who who I got to ask to get
these tests done what did you just get
blood testal do you have a coupon code
yeah you got like a website or something
like you got you got a website you got a
code is it like a subscription or
something uh just normal hospitals I
presumably you have to go back to check
up on like how like it's going is there
like what's is there any downsides to
getting like I you're probably not a
medical professional but I assume this
downsides to having like too much of
certain vitamins as well yeah yeah I
know like I picked the ones that I
needed not everything that he takes I
designated towards my like Diet uh so
some like half the stuff I'm not taking
some stuff I'm taking cuz I did like um
I've done blood tests for a couple years
now to see like how my vitamins are and
pretty much now I just did the mineral
test as well which are pretty expensive
cuz it charged like 20 bucks per one
mineral mhm which is uh wow yeah pretty
insane but I discovered some that I'm
missing for some reason which are like
kind of basic and so I'm just taking
those and uh I think some only last also
for half a year and then I'm going to
stop taking them right right right so
it's not like I'm doing it forever what
what do you think has been like the most
effective would is it the vitamins
absolutely no [__] idea I'm taking
like 20 of
them that's the it could just be AER for
all we know as well if it was that's
great I don't care yeah fair enough as
long as it works I mean yeah I think I'd
feel something putting 24 pills in my
body I'd either be floating by the end
of it or i' be I'd be scared to swallow
stuff for a while this episode is
sponsored by vessie boys I surrounded by
some god tier looking shoes and some
jackets it must be a vessie ass it's
vessie date I get to add another pair of
shoes to my collection I'm already way
ahead of you I'm already rocking my V
look at those kicks dog that's right if
you guys don't know we absolutely love
vessis honestly all we ever wear are
vessie shoes for any occasion because
vessie is built for any occasion rain
snow sleep or shine I even wore it's a g
wedding Conor what you're holding there
is a brand new pair of vessie Soho shoes
100 % waterproof gusseted tongue diex
technology synthetic leather exterior
grippy outsoles non-marking outsoles
pattered collar oh my God it's the
perfect shoe Jessie isn't just a shoe
company they make some jackets as well
specifically the overcast that both gun
and Connor are wearing right now it is a
100% waterproof jacket with a stretchy
shell soft fleece lining a Ragin sleeve
design adjustable Hood with a soft
curved hem and secure zipper pockets
it's perfect for any kind of winter
outdoor AC activities so if you want to
be like us and join the vessie gang go
to vessie
docomo pick yourself a pair or get
yourself one of these that's vessie
docomo the vessie gang today thank you
very much back to the episode actually I
brought some gifts oh you did damn all
right some
vitamins oh wait why did she bring this
wait what do mean I feel like uh maybe
we're a bit tired you know Dar just flew
here if you're tired gone you should
definitely drink this okay okay what's
this one so these are some really fancy
things I don't no you haven't really
said that in Japan but in every comini
there's like a wall of these little
liquids and they're supposed to be drank
like before drinking or after
drinking what the [__] this is like a
give you energy this is [__] yeah I
actually I actually drink one of these
every morning now oh sh actually works
better for me than a
coffee I drank one this morning and I'm
feeling good so that's really good wa
maku maku Maka is like U the hell is Mak
it's like a yeah exu extract what the
hell are you popping it open yeah this
one is EP this is also for like I think
this is more so for um hangovers and
stuff like that this is like a liver
kind of drink so it helps cleanse your
liver after a night of drink it you
drink this before you start drinking
yeah that's not an enery drink that's a
that's a hangover cure yeah yeah I was
like oh [__] is mud bringing us like
vodka or something when you bought out
the I'm like oh my God we call these
magic potions but why does it taste like
Red Bull just all of them taste like Red
Bull so like yeah one time I had this Cu
uh there's a drink called uh oron or
Oram I never can never [__] say that
orami it's basically just an enery drink
but I guess it's it looks like a vitamin
like kind of a like a medicine bottle
and Pete was like man I used to drink
those all the time when I was sick I'd
have like four of them I was like Pete
you know there's like 20 gr of sugar in
one of those he's like oh I guess I did
feel feel
something maybe that's why I felt sick
yeah I was like yeah if you drink four
energy drinks when you feel sick you're
go you're not going to feel much better
you're [__] gone bro God I remember
Christ yeah so that's Maka apparently is
also good for um uh erectile
[Laughter]
dysfunction MAA apparently it gets you
like Mega hard so uh wait what gets you
hard or is it it keeps it keeps I'll
give you an update in 20 yeah that's the
trash day special right
there entire trash day episode but we
all rock take Viagra and you will never
know which episode it is is is Viagra
over the counter in Japan I have no idea
I very much doubt in the UK they like a
few years ago they made it over the
counter really you can just rock up to
the store and byy Viagra what just like
at a convenience store yeah really yeah
damn so this episode is I'm
good my penis is healthy yeah but I very
much doubt it just just because there's
a lot like a lot of stuff that are over
the counter in other countries it's just
a lot harder to find in Japan they're
very much they s kind of wild just
having a rock hard penis completely out
of your
control but myag is prescription base
prescription prescription base here much
my my favorite like insane Mudan fact
that you told me that I don't know if
you still do this you told me that you
were spending like $1,000 a month on
fivera just finding editors oh no that
was a long time ago at the beginning
yeah that's crazy so run run through
that like how did you well Connor was
like all right I'm going to do a
highlights Channel I'm going to need
editors and I'm like okay I can handle
it and then he was like all right 5
hours of footage he's like all right how
about two videos a week can you do more
can you do four videos a week I'm like
no stop please but uh I just needed
editors fast so I went through fiber I I
spent so much time on fber trying to
find different editors I would say it's
I found some really solid editors there
like really talented who are still with
me but I would say out of like 50 people
that you test you find one person who
fits yeah and that's where you're like
sometimes I'd spend two grand and I
wouldn't even get like a video that's
usable at all right right right Jesus so
did you find that there was a
correlation between how much you paid
and how good the editor was yeah just
it's so i' pay like you know there's are
people who don't charge much so they'd
be like all right I do it for $10 and
then person who's like I do it for 200
both same quality really yeah like
literally so [__] fun if it costs
over 100 probably
[__] it's it's like the people in the
middle who are like 50 around $50 those
are good to find those a lot of them
also do it just to like get the food in
the door so there have been some people
who are like yeah I'm doing it right now
just to have my name out there and who
have actually like helped and now
they're editing for like the YouTubers
as well who started at $50 now they're
making you know a couple of RS I mean I
I think the biggest thing about being a
YouTuber at least for me personally
because you know we do work with a lot
of editors as well uh it's finding the
consistency uh and finding someone who
understands YouTube editing cuz I think
YouTube editing is very very different
from traditional media editing if
somebody does traditional media I'm
instantly like no that that doesn't work
cuz relearning is like almost impossible
but you can teach somebody from scratch
yeah uh question right away
what is one of the videos of Oz that
you've edited that just makes you
shudder when you think about it it's
just like the video you're like not
again any of our videos it's probably be
I probably I'm probably the Japan's
offishal right yeah well yeah that was
probably that so huge I guess the trash
T special always like it's so fun when
I'm in it but it's it's kind of like the
same with video games like you want to
get into it and you you know you're
going to spend the next 6 hours of your
life at least 6 hours minimum if you
don't have 6 hours of free time you're
not going to start on it but I never
have 6 hours of free time so it's really
hard to like get into the mindset of it
right cuz you usually learn on daily
basis I go through like 10 20 videos and
uh there's just not enough time to like
well you'll just open a video for 5
minutes and be like all right next video
no what do you mean you said 10 videos
right are you opening a video for like
30 minutes at a piece and then just I
mean it can be like 10 minutes some can
be two hours it depends like my job
right now like I I'm mostly the glue
that holds everything together I'm I'm
like the quality control so sometimes
like yeah I go over the video I'm like
all right that's cool uh maybe I just
change one or two things and sometimes I
like all right well that's like 4 hours
of my work just to like get it up to par
yeah so is there a video that you look
back on that you've edited for like any
of us that you're like this is this was
this was a tough one this was a tough
one I don't are there any like types of
videos where you're just like oh God
this is going to be a anime videos I
hate them so
much no like what you do is fine now but
I
would I would say that the old type
where you're like all right so I'm going
through Full Metal Alchemist in this
episode 36 uh they did that thing and
you'd be like all right well I have to
get the raw footage I have to go through
the entire season find that one specific
moment just for that two seconds and
then I have to do it again like 100
times I remember when we did the hentai
special I I just handed you all the
hentai yeah and then I guess you had to
go through it for the patreon version
and play the bits we were talking about
that was pretty compared to like because
there only a couple of episodes right
yeah this is why mudon doesn't edit for
my
channel how does Alan Do It um so we he
gets paid monthly
yeah yeah he has a salary which uh you
know I there's a big difference between
how we paid Mudan like or I guess how we
paid Mudan right now which is kind of
like more of a project per project basis
where for me and the editing team I have
for my channel it's a salaried kind kind
of based uh because I soon realized that
having them watch anime takes time and
it's weird to get build for someone
being like it took me 10 hours to watch
this many episodes of anime to find the
right footage you do forget that
sometimes yeah yeah yeah cuz you don't
really fact that in when you're editing
you know obviously the footage where
you're not it's not technically on the
timeline they're just kind of like maybe
they need to watch it to get familiar
with the material so I was just like I
think a salary kind like position works
better than a freelance position because
having to track your time when you're
like just watching anime it just it
tracks a lot harder as well yeah for
sure for sure yeah but I I got I I
always wanted to ask what was your
opinion when you edited the first Trash
taste episode and not like not like the
first one we released so the zero yeah
episode zero so the patreons will know
this we upload we recorded like an
episode zero uh where hey if you want to
see that
patreon.com where it was just like us
doing a it it was mostly just a camera
setup test where we're just setting up
to see if it looks good we recorded and
then we kept talking until like the
camera ran out even though it was like
only meant to be a test to see how Mudan
could uh make it look what was your
initial reactions when uh when you first
saw like the trash taste and uh what we
were going to be doing damn that's
easy so finally something easy finally
something easy to do so before that I
had like a similar type of uh content
that I was making and it was so intense
and so hard so like trash taste kind of
helped me pivot from that to like this
which is much easier and uh yeah I like
it you also handled it pretty well like
there was no awkwardness the like walls
were I guess weirdly empty and looking
back yeah yeah because we didn't have
any like background right yeah the
camera right now is like really natural
and in at the beginning it also seemed
really natural how it was so flat
looking back it's like wo that's weird
yeah yeah yeah when when I when I look
back to like our first like first season
trash taste episodes and this it goes to
the center camera I'm just like w I
don't remember the camera looking like
that like well it was really far away
cuz we didn't have well we didn't have
much money so we kind of just had a
camera that had a I think a 24 mm lens
which made it have to just be like at
the end of the room which gives it this
really weird look yeah of like you can
tell it's far away but very it's very
very interesting and no one could go in
the middle of the room like everyone had
to be in the corners cuz if you went
through the middle you'd be walking past
I don't remember what we even talked
about on that like pilot episode I don't
remember either it was it was a long
time ago what what's been your favorite
trash taste video to edit all the
specials all the specials I just I well
I love the specials it's literally like
the closest to TV shows that you make
and I also can well I love trash taste
cuz you don't have me like force me to
do anything it's like full creative
freedom so I can experiment with
whatever yeah yeah
well because everything you produce is
Banger bro like yeah it's it's all based
on a trust system right which is very
important oh yeah I I mean that's pretty
much what keeps me going like the
creative freedom cuz the moment that
somebody's like all right here's like
five sheets of exactly what you have to
do that's when I'm like okay this is a
job now I don't want to do it yeah cuz
like I remember it's it's funny that you
said that about anime footage cuz I
remember I think how we found you was
you were originally an anime YouTuber
right anim uh like how when I mean you
still kind of make you I can't remember
what was the last anime video you've
actually like made on your personal
Channel cuz Mudan does actually have a
personal Channel and personal streams
which you do to I guess figure out the
logistics Logistics and the landscape of
the other editing projects that you're
going to be doing I guess when did you
stop doing anime content I think like 3
years ago 3 years ago it was well I
didn't want to do it anymore right cuz I
was
passion happens to everyone eventually
except for this guy I mean yeah well you
go through so much anime everything
seems repetitive and then also like if
you do reviews it's like what new can I
say to this like I don't have that
natural Charisma or like ideas to bring
to the table without it going too stale
yeah but I think when I found you what
what said you apart immediately from a
lot of other anbers was just like again
like you had this like it wasn't just
like a sit in front of a camera do a
review type of thing you know go through
episodes throw on a joke that kind of
stuff like you know I think what made
like you and you know in the same way
that made ga uh very unique in the anti
sphere was just that you guys had like
your own flavor that made it instantly
like this is a giga video or like this
is a moodon video and in your case you
were just like going so bols to the
walls with your editing I I remember I
was just like every like 3 seconds it
was just like oh there's an After
Effects thing there's an After Effects
thing it like it it just seemed like so
over the top but I think that was like
one of the big reasons why I like
decided to like get you to edit for me
was just like no one in the anbe sphere
is editing like this you know no one's
making videos like this and I think
that's what kind of set you apart from
everyone else you know yeah well when I
started anbe I only did it for two
reasons cuz uh I like I wanted to be a
YouTuber in a way uh but I didn't have
much to talk about so it was either
video games or anime there like the two
hobbies and already did video games for
like a year and that got nowhere so I
was like all right anime
why did you go for video games first uh
I don't know it's more basic everybody
does it I wanted to see if it works but
I think the big issue was I did not
really I guess commit to the community
cuz I did not speak to anybody and in a
year of like doing videos I did not grow
at all but I did learn like a lot of
important stuff with for editing so when
I started anbe I actually went to like
Community boards interacted with members
uh did like community events and it was
really fun and that's how I met a lot of
people I think maybe like like some of
you as well through some of that yeah I
can't remember when I first met you must
have been some Anime Expo I think first
it's always anime when you know the
anime Community was still a thing and
people met up at Anime Expo uh old
days the good old days um weren swamped
yeah so you've been doing a lot more
streams now I got to ask what made you
want to do the stream where you sat in a
white room doing [__] nothing dude I
want to I want to steal this idea so bad
the one where we raided you when you
specifically texted us not to raid you
yeah you were doing the after dark and I
was like all right I'm going to do this
I'm going to message Connor do please do
not rate me I didn't see the message and
I'm like okay I I'll message Joey in
case as well Joey also didn't see the
message cuz we were live I think at the
time what was the concept of the stream
you want to tell people what it was uh
so pretty much I went into a white room
like I took a friend's apartment room uh
made the floors white with like sheets
everything white like the camera would
be just a lens I'd cover everything up
and I would just stay there essentially
it be like a subathon but for every sub
I'd stay there for like a minute or 2
minutes longer damn and how long were
you in there for it wasn't that long it
like 13 hours well you said you said I
started the [__] with you right oh yeah
absolutely it was horrible yeah I mean
you literally put yourself in a psych
Psychiatric Hospital solitary
confinement in solitary confinement
there's been a lot of studies that say
that like being in that kind of
environment like after even like a few
days can like really cause some mental
well that was that vsource video right
it's really really bad for you where I
got the idea from actually like Michael
did it I was like hm well he did a you
most of my streams have been like well
people have done YouTube videos I want
to I can do it live on a stream instead
so I was like you and Conor have the
same mindset with yeah I want to do that
too I want to have somewhere the chat
can [__] with me though I feel like that
like kind of messes up the dynamic of a
white room soz I'm going more for the
normal type of psychological torture
kind of like the like the zoo type of
vibe right where people just look in but
you can't interact I feel I feel like
that's boring though cuz you can leave
okay we have to say for twitch you can
always leave it's not
torture yeah you can leave anytime you
want so yeah does a lot of streams and a
lot of the time mud does streams and
then I'll see which ones are like not
[__] and then I'll I'll just take the
ideas before you did the treadmill
stream that seemed pretty [__] yeah
but I thought that'd be easy honestly
what do you mean it was so bad it's like
14 hours of pain for me yeah I thought
no I could do it I I looked at and I was
like this is one of the more achievable
moodang ideas and was it like as
achievable as you hoped yeah but it was
miserable it was an awful idea yeah so I
did this stream where uh the viewers
could control or you did it first so but
you did one where you walked 100,000
steps yeah I wanted to do 100,000 steps
on stream without stopping even once so
I got a Trad Mill I had like different
activities planned and it was also like
a donor on so people gave money Joey
graciously like fed pretty much 100 dogs
by himself yep because it was funny and
that also gave me like 20,000 more steps
you're welcome um and and so you did
that and I thought well that's good but
I don't want to do it as crazy and in my
head I was like that's a cool idea but I
feel like marathon is such a good
clickbait word because it's such a
strong association with like and it's
easy to understand right yeah yeah
100,000 steps is I mean it's it's it's
much better than a marathon if you terms
of distance but I was like Marathon I
think makes sense so I did that but I
was like What if I let the viewers
control the speed of the treadmill right
so I I I got one of my moderators um to
program a treadmill that we could use
with the chat interactivity it was
miserable it's horrible I realized how
bad it is that someone else controls
your speed like that was the single most
worst aspect of it that you couldn't get
a pace that sounds like it yeah I wonder
if that's like actually worse than going
at the same pace for double the distance
I think I would I don't know it's hard
to say your Rhythm right yeah yeah
because the moment I would get
comfortable they would change it yeah
and it would they could there was no
delay on the inputs they could they were
changing it every half second I thought
about going faster at points as well but
after doing a couple tests I figured out
that no it has to be exactly the same
amount the entire way through otherwise
it's like too much like muscle effort
yeah you need your legs to get like so
used to it and like like the like when
CU when you stop walking at any point
your legs are
like also it like [__] with your
balance as well right which is important
cuz like if if you're nice and balanced
on a treadmill then it's like less
energy everyone has like an optimal
stride yeah and like stride that is like
least resistance for you and you'll find
it by [__] around on a treadmill or
like it's what you running on a
treadmill as well and you're like I
could run faster but I will be able to
run way less than like the next 30
minutes if I do this because I it's just
going to be more work for me yeah for
sure um that was miserable so but good
luck editing that video that's an eight
hour video going up in a couple days is
it really is it fun it must have been
awful to edit uh it was decent cuz you
didn't do much yeah it was kind of hard
to do anything it was like you
complaining for 50% of the time was kind
of it yeah that's just every Conor video
well that's a lot of it that's a lot of
it just Conor in general in fact but hey
was only a one stream M messaged me one
time was like Conor you you got to stop
doing these streams that are like five
streams into one video yeah he's talking
about he has fear and hunger videos
how's it editing that many hours good
well the videos perform well I know the
videos are going to do well but he he
does like all right fear and hunger fear
and hunger all endings then it was like
uh something else that was like 20 hours
and for like a month straight you only
filmed videos that were 20 to 30 hours
long and each video takes like a month
to edit and you need two videos out a
week it's like please make a meme revie
yeah so so then a
m so then I was like all right honey yes
honey I'll I'll make a meme review and
then every time you go like on a trip I
need to be like we don't have enough
videos please yeah I have then I've had
to yesterday I to do a streamway did two
videos in one right um I'm fine with the
backlog but for some reason every time
winter comes you're like M on can we do
four videos a week I'm like can we get
so for so for context uh mood and runs
my streaming Channel but we like we
split the uh the the ad Revenue that we
get um and we we kind of like I guess we
strategize on how to make it like
perform well yeah and a lot of the time
it sucks but if you like cut up videos
like a lot of people would rather just
watch 1 hour of something have it go
through it all then four videos of 15
minutes yeah for sure which which is bad
for the YouTube channel if you're trying
to upload two two a week cuz it's like
okay now how do we keep this going cuz
some some games you know like they just
they naturally run their course at like
20 hours of playtime yeah but if you
split up into two videos the first video
will get tons of views and no one's
going to watch the second video because
it's just how that's just how it goes
for some reason all old YouTube used to
be able to get away with that but now
you should upload 30 [__] Parts I
know and you watch all them yeah and now
I'll do like like a 100 hour playr I'm
like can you get into one video
please um so yeah Dam how do you how do
you keep saying during those types of
videos where it's just like one thing
cuz I mean I I I have this same problem
where I send my editors like the 20th
genin video and they're like please gone
please do something else I B of you and
I'm like all right I got you honkai star
baby oh my God we'll do it like back to
back you know like honai genin honkai
gen mix it up got to spread it out you
got to spread it out
and then and then I'm like all right
fine I'll do a teer list video it's it's
okay it's okay I'll do an Igan anime
list revie it's fine this episode is
sponsored by Harry's with Harry's you
get highquality German engineered blades
right to your door every order saves you
money compared to that Big Brand most
guys are used to buying get them as low
as get this boys $2 per blade $2 but
only if you go to harry's.com traste as
you guys know I've been using Harry's
for like 2 years now exclusively uh it's
pretty much the only razor I used I used
some of the big Brands before I'm not
going to name a shame but I definitely
prefer Harry's and uh there's a reason
why whenever I can go and buy them cuz
they don't sell in Japan unfortunately a
smooth shave shouldn't be rough in your
wallet the trial set is a $13 value at
just $3 at harry's.com trash taste it
includes a five blade German engineered
razor weighted handle foaming shave
cream and a travel cover oh you and you
can schedule delivery refills for as low
as $2 half of what you would pay for the
blades haris has the highest customer
satisfaction in the Shaving industry and
they're still offering a no risk trial
guys you don't like your shave no
problem it's on them you can cancel your
subscription at any time as well so get
a subscription that saves you time and
money with Harry's get started with a
$13 trial set for just $3 at harry's.com
trashtaste that's harry's.com traste for
a $3 trial set back to the episode I I
got to ask has there ever been a point
where you've been watching a trash taste
episode and something one of us has said
has made you like legitimately
angry multiple times I've noticed I've
started to notice in recent trash chase
episodes whenever someone says something
usually Corner uh there's like a little
like window that pops up being like um
actually yeah this is very helpful to
have actually yeah well it works
sometimes when you're kind of doubting
yourself as well but sometimes I don't
notice it cuz you're like well yeah
that's true for sure just you just say
it out there I don't even notice that
you're like yeah that's a fact you know
I know this like all right okay what
okay what is the most egregious F thing
that we said was a fact that was wrong I
know the most annoying thing was uh why
do they put the white uh paint on
airplanes ohz oh cuz there's no solid
answer online the [__] up thing was
that you looked on the Google like why
is uh why is it that and it said oh cuz
black paint is heavier and then somebody
Googled some other thing and it said
doser but the thing was it was literally
both of them in the same article and at
at the end of the article it just said
this statement is false and then the
statement it just
said what the [__] is the point of that
article then Jesus no it's Google that
like picks the correct answer but it
like messes up well Google Google is has
this bad thing where if you feed it the
qu the answer you want like you ask the
question in a way it will find an
article that gives you the answer that
you kind of were looking for a lot of
the time uh which is kind of bad cuz a
lot of the time you're like yes I guess
I'll Trust the first thing that PO yeah
yeah which is annoying and yeah so like
the Mudan fact checks that like are on
screen every so often we did not tell
him to put that
on I'll do myself that was a him thing
and we kind of just I didn't we need it
I didn't even notice it and people until
people started commenting about it like
oh thank God mud on is backck I'm like
oh my God this is such a brilliant
idea back checks are very helpful with
some of things you said I was like well
this I I can't do this anymore you
so what's he talking about it's also
like some of the things need like a wall
of text for context my girlfriend's also
optometrist she she's uh studied like
how the eyes and stuff work and you have
a lot of hot takes about um you know
dark mode and how glasses work and she
just keeps editing and was like bro what
are they saying it's so [__] up and
then I'd hear like a 10-minute rant
about how all is wrong like all
right you do well wait isn't is is it
actually that okay I'm going to give you
on right now so you can work with isn't
it that like light mode actually is
better for your eyes or something the
way the contrast works if you have
astigmatism astis then it's like better
cuz you perceive like the contrast is
better yeah okay okay yeah well then
there we go check on the SP yeah sounds
like a skill issue so it's literally SK
day Get Better Eyes in yeah good eyes
I'm I'm sorry I don't have 2020 Vision
guys all right call me out okay I'm I'm
trying okay I'm trying
I'm going to I'm going to get surgery
eventually C literally uh she recently
actually just got I uh she convert back
to dark
mode I mean good question good question
let you know I don't think she ever has
ever should try it okay here's the thing
she's now that I think about it she's
also a light mode user but that's
because it's just default in most apps I
just don't think she uh so she
just another fact that mud's going to
have to
check I think the most common surgery in
the world is like the uh the replacing
the lens of your eye um cataracts is it
oh c but you know cuz you when you you
just age naturally it gets cloudier so
they just when you get older you just
get it changed at some point I think
that's the most common surgery I really
hope when this episode goes up the box
is just going to say no you that would
be so but I'm setting it up so good if
I'm right POG if I'm wrong okay you're
an idiot they're also like so good at
doing it now but you'll probably we'll
all probably have to get it when we're
if we make it to 80 yeah well mown
certainly will with all his vitamins but
I'm it's very questionable I'll make it
no I I knew I did the 23m me with the
genetics me too me too they are going to
get [__] up oh [__] really what El
what other health things did they tell
you dude me too oh [__]
yeah [__] yeah
Dem I actually forgot about that
I'm yeah they said uh Alzheimer's as
well they said I had a high chance and I
was [__] myself because they said oh
you have a high chance of Alzheimer's
like [__] okay that sounds and they
click on it and and their like highrisk
category meant like 1% extra chance or
something I was like right I was like
bro are you kidding me I gamble with way
worse odds I'll take 1% I they also
check like one like sequence out of 50
possible ones so even if that's low the
other can be high so well yeah cuz mine
said like like like very low chance of
balding so that was a [__] lie so
that was a lie straight line go watch
the video it's still on YouTube you can
see it wow we should uh I I should I
should do one and then we should
it on trash you know what's annoying did
you get this emails all the time cuz I
did I did the ancestry and I did we
found a new we found a new cousin I
don't [__] care I don't want a new
cousin I don't want any cousins I get
that so often I have to muted just my
life
like I was going to say I was like this
is how much like how Gant describes all
his relationships just like we found
three cousins I don't one of the [__]
new cousins I don't know I'm happy with
the cousins I have it's like every
family meeting I have I'm just like oh
that's a a new cousin like a cousin
cousin or like a
cousin and they're like yes but you know
if I'm like three connections away not
like like it's so like sparse the
connection I'm like yeah why are you
telling me I don't care would who does
this interest yeah I'm not going to go
meet [__] Barry Dinger in [__] you
know North Barry Dinger like North
Carolina's like fourth remov like I'm
not going to go [__] meet him but you
can travel all over the world you just
have a place to that's a Mr that's a Mr
Beast video I contact all of my cousins
for a battle
royale you're probably wondering why
I've all dragged you into the group chat
only one of us can continue the
bloodline we're going to decide right
now that's just an average Asian
household except we to go over
inheritance from our grandma
true that is true that that is just a
yeah Asians are like yeah we do that
every generation actually that's why I'm
really good to my
grandma well do you think we're going to
get immortality within our lifetime cuz
like I don't know because I mean he's
going to get a f yeah yeah yeah I'm like
if anyone's going to outlive anyone it's
going to be Mudan not immortality they
might the deing Stu deing is what I
really bro you don't mortal so you get
if you get hit by a [__] truck let's
see how mortal you are don't get hit by
truck doesn't Japan have like the higher
stage of like yes anymore it's Hong Kong
now was it Hong Kong [__] but how did he
do it did he just drink the little
bottles little [__] bottles but I
think just the diet right the diet like
the average Japanese person just doesn't
have a [__] Diet also just naturally I
think a lot of Japanese foods are just
standardized to be more healthier than
other like Cuisines and but they do have
one of the highest rates of or higher
rate of stomach cancer because of all
the salt they generally use so just your
salt and um I think it's just genetic
diff I don't think it's a genetic diff
you think you don't think it's genetic
diff I think I think it's diet it's all
diet G it's it's probably diet I mean
there might be some genetic stuff I feel
like genetics has okay you're going to
have a awful
time I like looking at me being like oh
for [__] sake when I'm when I'm at a r
and they give me half of these Foods I'm
like yeah no [__] I'm going to be
immortal if I eat all this I'm like not
I don't know what half of this [__] is
and half of it is slimy and I feel like
it tastes H I'm pretty sure you can get
every vitamin from the oh absolutely
absolutely yeah like is Super Foods a
thing yes or is it just like yes yes but
the problem is let me introduce you to
broccoli gar and kale they have
superfoods the problem with super
super cuz they have insane benefits to
the human body do they uh I I assume so
fact check this like the only reason
wake me up when we have Ultra Foods man
when are they coming out yeah where's
the next level from Super I want an
Ultra Food you know then like people
then people like they're like oh kale
superfood let me blend it and then it
somehow loses all like a bunch of its
traits that allow it to be absorbed into
your body oh yeah isn't that the same
thing with like fruit as well yeah
smoothies too if you blend them um it's
not as I don't know what the blending
process does where all the vitamins are
just like see you it's like buy
something or when you grill something
it's like you know some foods become a
lot less healthy when you grill ory them
like the problem I find with a lot of
these like you know health benefit kind
of things is that like how much research
has actually gone into it cuz I I swear
to God you know sometimes I'll see like
a a video or an article being like I
recommend this diet or I recommend these
kinds of foods and then someone will
come out and say actually that's not as
effective as this kind of thing and then
you get to the point where you're like
actually this is bad for your body you
know and and you just like I get to a
point where I'm like I don't even know
what the [__] trust no my my
favorites are the ones where like these
like food researchers like try to kind
of create a uh create like a middle
ground of being like all right we get
you guys want to eat french fries so
we're going to release an article I
remember I saw this [__] article five
french fry one it's like Harvard
professors recommend five french fries a
day it's like ain't nobody eating five
fries a day list you can eat [__] food
but I think the general consensus is hey
just eat less eat the amount of calories
your body needs and generally eat uh
grains or not grain um like whole grains
or like veg or you know stuff that are
high that are good for you you can eat
the bad things should eat the things
that are good for you too don't just
drink [__] Dr Pepper and Nuggets you
you know what the biggest [__] lie I
think is that I'm going to just say our
gut feeling what 9 out of 10 doctors
recommend this product and I'm like
where where where are the 10 doctors no
my other question who is asking the 10
doctors here no my other question is
who's the one doctor that didn't
recommend
it no because obviously if they say 10
out of 10 doctors recommend this
everyone's going to be like [__] you
say n out of 10 like w well even n out
of 10 I'm kind of like [__] n out of
10 doctors that are on our payroll that
we pay to do the research for this
product uh recommend our product by the
way yeah I don't think it's working
anymore that's why they're like these
YouTubers recommend our
products n out of 10 YouTubers recommend
this product yeah cuz like I this is
going to be total [__] because like
you know the whole [__] why do
Japanese people age better I don't I
don't know if anyone really knows is
think the Japanese know it's just like
we're guessing that it's diet you know
it might just be genetics it might it
might could be [__] anything I don't
[__] know I really don't know yeah
but you know I don't know how much
actual study or research has gone into
this or if it's just like you know if
it's like a
scientifically backed study that has
been like approved by a lot of
scientists or is it just like or is it
just like one independent study to be
like just be
healthier try better have better better
yeah yeah problem is though like you
want to apply a lot of these things to
your life but you only get one [__]
chance if you [__] up you read the wrong
article you're [__] you there's so
many articles that's like 10 years later
they look back and it's like yeah that
was actually very bad exactly right I I
I remember vividly when I was in school
um like there was this like article in
in Australia or maybe the world I don't
know but I remember in school there was
this article which was just like oh
scientists have concluded that uh boiled
eggs are actually bad for you and it was
just this entire article about that
people were like well [__] I got to cook
eggs in a different way literally 2
weeks later it was just like actually
they're good for you
so it's just like what do you want like
do you want to Ste them or they used to
have smokes with fiberglass filter and
that was supposed to be the British with
asbestos yeah oh they used to sell
menthol cigarettes with asbestos lining
which
is which which okay okay which is [__]
F hit me out hit me out that's life
speed if you survive that and you live
till 80 you just buil [__] bi yeah
they needed to social on you like he
smoked asbestos all his life and he's
still somehow alive yeah I'm not
stressing too much about it I I I'll
just let my I'll let nature run its
course is there like a is there like an
age you want to get to like like like a
goal age where you're like it you know
it' be pretty cool if I I just don't
want to be taken care of yeah I'm the
same yeah so whatever age that is just
living like the last 30 years like yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly I just want to
have like an off switch uh you know
that's I know it's called but you
know you want a game end okay that's
that's the I'm going to go that gameer
guys
on you
should I think the game is called it
sding but uh in in in the perfect world
uh I would just like you know I would
just like to have to a point where my
body just stops working and then it just
like shuts down that's a heart attack
you're describing stroke heart attack uh
a bunch of other diseases can do this
too would you would you ever want to get
to the point though like we've all
watched futur right yeah yeah you know
in like Futurama they have like all the
heads would you ever want to get to that
point sounds how good the new Apple
Vision Pro is
on [__] it I don't know well I mean they
got to get rid of this thing right yeah
how can you jack off just you you have
the urch don't never be an urch to jack
off that
sucks I live dayto day with the
knowledge of knowing that I'm going to
have a a great session of jacking off
okay there's there's a few things I'll
be like I'll be like as a head I'll be
like Siri play the video where the guy
goes bans and I'll just watch it on like
forever it's and and like you wouldn't
be able to enjoy a meal like ever again
but imagine how much editing you can get
yeah
true imagine the video games and Anime
you could get through as a head as a
sentient head mud's like enjoying a meal
nah editing the new trash taste special
in my mind with my eyes okay now I'm now
I'm getting
excited is you ever felt like man I got
a problem I like editing too much that
was like seven years ago I accepted it
now oh I'm like I'm at like second
step what's what's the second step I
know acceptance that's the final step wa
you have to like do something about it
after good then yeah there's there's
more steps where you you overcome I'm
good I'm here I'm
good he's achieved his goal all right
fair enough fair enough what' you like
to do in your
downtime [__] please tell me you
have please tell me you have downtime
let me rephrase the question for forgot
do you have downtime uh I mean yeah sure
uh how much do you want I don't know
what what do you like to do when you're
like I don't have anything to do
urgently I can kind of get to whatever
or well that's why on holiday I mean I
assume you're on holiday right now right
he's been he's editing this video in his
mind as it's being filmed
the first two days here I was in the
office trying to get the new uh episode
out Christ we're so sorry but I I pretty
much picked up streaming just for that
reason so I could do new stuff so like
half their Hobbies I do through streams
so it's like
combination right so you you you're the
same as Conor where you're like you you
find streaming is like it's fun man it's
fun I really like it it's fun having an
audience to like just do dumb [__] with
fair enough just test ideas I don't
think g i are in that camp I'm like
Mudan please take a holiday no we're
telling you to take a you were telling
you to take a employe I'm a
freelancer you have no control over my
health I mean vitamins damn it I need to
take a quick piss all right all
right all right do something funny for
the
patreon no this episode is sponsored by
gamer Subs gamer Subs is launching a
brand new product it's called gamer tea
gamer tea finally something that my
British taste can handle guys let's
check this out inside this box there are
four different types of tea from black
ginger turmeric sleepy time and yba
matter each box comes with 15 tea bags
bags should be added to hot water like
you normally would to make hot tea each
box is $15 and on the 13th of October
gamer Subs is launching Wu cup season
5.5 royalty with the purchase of a 5.5
royalty Wu cup you can get one free box
of your choice of gamer tea D look I've
been trying to say that that just
because you're a gamer doesn't mean you
need to drown yourself in energy drinks
and all that let's bring out the tea
baby this is for those classy Gamers who
like suffering over the course of
multiple hours and need a drink that can
just last the entire day what tea do you
want Conor what's what's your tea of
choice you want want some ultimately I'm
a basic [__] I want some black tea get
some ginger to Rick and you what the
[__] I I'll take the black tea thank you
very much give me the black tea give me
that I need some uh sleepy time this
will help me get to sleep and as always
you can use code trash taste at checkout
to get yourself a little discount as
well so become a real gamer today and
use our link and use code trash taste
guys become a real gamer drink some tea
get some Britain in you guys like a good
old brexit Geer get the sh get back to
the episode so like a few weeks ago uh
me and Mudan were hanging out and and I
just kind of remember this and patreon
or no no this I guess this is the
episode now uh we we I can't wait for
Connor to tell the story uh so we hang
out and we had a like like a night where
we were dressed up a bit U we were
taking some photos uh and then as soon
as like that part of the night's over
mud's like go is part of not over and
I'm like yeah great I want to rip this
shirt I'm I'm like Mudan why and he's
like I want
to oh the $300
gone waa oh [__] I didn't realiz how far
back I went you you broke our [__]
set more than lady beard did I guess I
did huh how did you do more damage than
all of the earthquakes we've had over
the past couple of years yeah I brought
some more gifts yeah okay what other
gifts did you bring well I know there's
a classic japanese delicacy that you
haven't really uh shown off much why
would you bring this we have shown this
off have you I think we've shown this
off on an episode one you know call me
degenerate I actually kind of like I
don't like this yeah that's pretty good
get the [__] I actually kind of like
these it's called Maru and what is this
Cherry tell us tell the audience what it
is uh this is um Maru which is basically
uh Japanese sake in
a c how much would this cost it's about
110 Yen it's like the cheapest S80 cents
for 200 MERS of hard alcohol I think
every country that's POG it's POG about
it [__] it's so cheap and it's suck it's
Japanese every country has an equivalent
of [__] that's like super cheap that you
only drink when you're like really
really young are we comping do I have to
Camp I already took a sip oh my God
y
godie newbie
Camp Jesus guys I'm jet lagged as [__]
this I don't like Sak well people love
your drunk episodes so yeah well I don't
think I'm going to get drunk today not
with this [__] I got it I need some nice
nice
alcohol what the [__] Mudan what Mudan
what why did you down that well I mean M
was the small why are you so unhinged is
it not a shot class no okay rule number
okay I'm going to tell the audience this
especially Americans did you shot that
yeah why I'm I'm going to say 200 M I'm
going to say this on camera okay
Americans sake is not meant to be shoted
you are not supposed to shot sake it's a
sippy drink M you're not supposed to
shot sake it's a sippy drink why is it
in such a small bottle then this is 200
M what do you mean this is a lot of sck
it's just a big shortcut
oh you could say that about any vessel
say that about this no he's he con
sh I can see the I can see the cogs
turning I'm going to shout this water
dare me again this is what happens when
you have an an aonian
on it's not
bad it's actually not bad he he just
doesn't like sock same with this I don't
like this kind of oh Christ it's like
lighter fluid what this really nice
this is how you treat your guests when
they bring gifts a gift you brought me
the Dollar
Store what do they uh what do they drink
in Estonia normally I guess
vodka [__] yeah I guess like that's
one thing I want to ask cuz like I've
been AR and I have been wanting to like
uh go to Estonia just because we know
someone in Estonia now um what what's it
like like cuz I think before meeting you
I knew nothing of Estonia didn't even
know Estonia existed I know Estonia is
like high-tech is it high-tech it is
pretty Hightech oh really we have like
uh you can do more why did you live in a
why did you live in a log cabin then do
you can you choose where you're born or
where you live
the are you like are you like why are
you
poor I didn't mean like why you poor me
then damn why hold up you live in a log
cabin oh yeah my mom had a log cabin
like outside the city like okay it was a
house it made out of
logs like when you say Log Cabin you
usually mean like a resort or something
but it's it's a house right right okay
okay and you you live there growing up
or yeah and you had a good internet
there no that's why like everything that
I pretty much do in life to advance is
because of trash taste I moved to the
city to have better internet to download
your insane like files upgraded my PC
like changed uh routs everything wow
well you're welcome first of all
now you can game at fast
speed when did you realize you really
liked editing cuz like you you said you
got into YouTube to do like just content
and [__] but now you I feel like you're
definitely just like you are the only
editor I know this going to sound bad
you're the only editor I know that
actually enjoys the process of editing
as opposed to like I like editing but I
hate 90% of it but I like the final
products and the fun parts of editing
but you genuinely seem to like every
single aspect of editing secret to like
liking editing I don't think there's a
secret but well apparently there is cuz
a lot of YouTube editors are just like
oh god well I think I think not not to
and put my own uh kind of thoughts I
think some some people think that like
editing is a is a way to get into
YouTube sometimes and it's kind of like
like they're in it for the wrong reasons
well I I think some people want to be
YouTubers and they think it means to an
end yeah I think some people it's a way
to get the foot in the door and
sometimes it actually is but I think
sometimes that YouTube is so mainstream
people know that you can make money from
it so they want to it but like editing
is Art like why do people like drawing
why do people like I don't know making
video games it's just creation and for
me it's the same it's not just editing
you know I like uh filming and stuff as
well I'm just the best at editing so to
me it's just making art I guess okay so
it's just it's just making content [__]
I don't know my my videos are art all
right thanks for moving on trash taste
is a work of art guys painted
by next to MOA all
[__] Conor in like the [__] museum
being like and this is my ninth crane
grain my finest work if I do say so
myself this is an excellent piece
derivative of my previous work but still
OD
nonetheless oh my
God jeez so I was going to say something
I totally forgot the sake is just like
hacked my mind already no no I prefer a
beer I got to ask do you lose brain
cells when you this probably should I
don't know if I should say do you lose
brain cells when you edit our
sponsored sponsors don't watch the main
episode fine sponsors are very basic I'd
say uh they I I don't spend that much
time on them and like by now I already
know like every everything so in the
beginning I I would say sponsors are one
of the hardest credits cuz those are
actual job like you need to go through
the document to see what has to be
included what not go through like 20
minutes of outakes of us trying to say
one I'm I'm convinced in like the the
depths of my mind that Mudan has this
this file on his PC that is all of my
like me cursing mid sponsor ad reads
well I used to have then you were like
oh M can we do patreon bloopers I'm like
a damn all right can't collect anymore
because sometimes I'll do this for ad
read and I'll get halfway through I'm
like [__] [__] [__] because I can't say
the word or something have like a mental
breakdown and only he's ever going to
see it those are the good ones those are
the good ones yeah good ones yeah I just
see like a long pause in the waveform
like and then one word in the middle and
then long pause and like all right
what's what's happening there sometimes
that happens I'll be I'll open a sponsor
or something I'll open a do something
I'm going to record it and I'm like wait
I don't have the right stuff to do this
and I'll sit there looking on my PC for
5 minutes and I realize that it's just
like blank been rolling me looking like
this what the [__] is that what the [__]
is what the [__] is this okay moov on is
it true you edit at full time speed
uh I go through the videos mostly two
times depends on the videos right but
yeah like this podcast can be done four
times a speed well actually no
physically you make it sound so easy no
physically it can cuz four times the
speed like you lose audio in premiere
for some reason so uh right now I do had
three you're being held back by the
machine your brain's like I can handle
four the computer I used to when I used
to do a lot of my own audio editing um
for voiceover I I could I'd to the point
where I could recognize words from the
waveform cuz i' would always say them
the same way so I could recognize
exactly where the words were and I think
uh you said something the same thing one
time as well you were like you
recognized your fo my
[__] I guess cuz I it's the same exact
way from [__] let's see if you see it in
the endit um uh there was also a thing
you you you said to me one time you were
like I think I'm you even though we're
friends you like I think I'm parasocial
with you guys
yeah it's so weird cuz like
I I get so much of your content like
Conor every single day trash taste like
a lot of times in the week I watch more
trash taste than a normal viewer cuz I
go through multiple times like I manage
so much I'm like it it's so hard cuz I I
I feel like I'm here or
like I don't understand how this works
cuz we're technically friends we talk
like outside of like stuff but also I
feel like I know more about you and I
can never like position myself
I know sometimes Joy's being like Oh
yeah we should like catch up like let's
have a call I'm like I know what you
did I don't we don't need to talk I
don't need it I already know everything
I've already talked to you in my mind
I'll be I'll be honest you have nothing
to say to me yeah I'll be honest I
actually feel the exact same way when I
see like these boys' content when
they're like doing something else it it
feels weird I don't know like I remember
watching your video with Anthony filla
and I'm just like like this feel
weird yeah I'm like I don't know it was
it was like super weird just seeing you
go through like this interview and yeah
I was watching that video and I was just
like I already know this yeah yeah well
yeah I I it's hard when I do interviews
now cuz I'm like how because it's
obviously the interviews appeal to my
audience right but then it's also you're
trying to make it so that uh Anthony or
whoever's audience is also aware but in
my head I'm like man I just it's
impossible to give anything
anym to people who know me already say
everything I mean that's what happens
when we have what like 100 hours of us
just we're nearly at 200 episodes like I
can't possibly do an interview that will
be like
interesting yeah so like anyone who
watch the Anthony P you're like you're
just getting the the rehash you're just
getting like the the breakdown pretty
much um so yeah I guess yeah but but
also sometimes I feel like I don't know
it's Maybe dirty is the wrong word but
it just feels wrong I we know each other
we we know each other and if if there's
a part of that video where you haven't
mentioned to me I'm like I should have
asked him about
that just be like why did you hide this
from
us why do I not I should know
everything I think mud knows literally
everything about me yeah it is like I
think M knows everything about us yeah
pretty much I yeah we have trash taste
and then you have all of my main and
second challenges you know literally
everything I do in my life that's that's
not thing that's I feel like I feel like
the real thing is seeing the like the
footage that goes in between like the
highlights and everything that's got you
see us you see us at our best and our
worst when we're on and when we're
off and I think that's the biggest thing
where I realized that you know Mudan
sees everything that we film on the
specials uh that he chooses not to put
in the video which uh is is a lot there
a lot of there have been a lot of videos
that I filmed and I have left that day
being like holy [__] I did awful I was
just not funny I didn't I wasn't there
and then Mudan sends me the edit and I'm
like okay it's okay and then I add voice
over and I watch it and I'm like huh
maybe I am funny it seems like I I had a
lot of fun but I distinctly remember I
didn't have fun doing this um to be real
like all your off moments are still
pretty good like I've edited for some
people who are literally doing it for
content and they're like yes so we're
going to go we're going to do this and
then wi C is like [__] what scrip again
[__] I hate this so much like literally
180 and I'm like w that's awful I think
honestly that's that's shooting in Japan
cuz I think uh when the cameras turn off
in Japan especially if you're doing
stuff um in on a location with other
people such Japanese people you it's so
bizarre cuz there's always this level of
like professionalism that you have to
maintain and I noticed that like uh if I
behave too differently to camera and
then when the camera cuts and the energy
changes I I feel sometimes they get
confused they're like they don't
understand like what I'm doing because
they don't understand what I'm saying so
sometimes if I'm talking in English and
my energy is totally different I think
sometimes people are like H it's this
weird vibe I got and so I try to always
like keep when I go in there I'm giving
them the same energy that throughout I
don't know why I I subconsciously do
this but yeah I just something I just
kind of picked up doing I I got a lot
when like filming with Japanese people
um I I get like a thing a lot where
people are like wow you're like exactly
the same off camera and I'm like are you
not like what are you doing that's like
so different cuz like I've had so many
I'm obviously not going to name the
shows but like a few Japanese shows I
went on it was like it was as you said
it was like a full 180 with some people
where it's like when they're on camera
they're just like the most like [__]
gearos like most extravagant like loud
and like personality type thing the
moment like someone's like all right cut
they just
like bring me my latte you know like
it's it's like that level I wish we had
someone to bring lattes oh that's called
Uber Eats yeah the Uber Eats guy does do
it yeah he does comes in clutch that one
guy definitely definitely knows who we
are he's delivering our Uber Eats thank
you for keeping it a secret but yeah
there's so many YouTubers who are like
completely
180 who even edited for see guys we're
real we're
real par social with
us you'll be happy to know we're exactly
the same more paral we are everything
you see on camera is us 100% we are not
bullshitting
anything God I hate that you're
[Music]
true D I was like I really want to out
the
window at the window at the
window
right actually he's right he's a real
one we real one he's telling the truth
well cuz I I had I had this distinct
thing and I I I had this um when I was
doing like the Sebastian stuff I had
this this this fear that people would
think I wasn't
smart and I don't know why I was scared
people would think I was Dumb and so I
would never ever try to say anything
that was even remotely fact checkable or
anything like that I would just keep it
and I would limit where I would appear
cuz I was like man I just don't want to
talk about me cuz I know I'm [__]
dumb uh and if I talk and open my mouth
and I rant for 10 minutes I'm going to
say something stupid wow trash tast
really changed you absolutely and then
after a while I was like man it's
exhausting like having to like be
careful about what I'm saying all the
time like keeping the act up right well
kind of playing almost like a character
um that's how we get the best Clips well
me just saying dumb [__] no I know that
now like I know that like it's more
entertaining when I'm just just being me
the whole reason why you know that's the
secret to trash T yeah and then and then
I realized I was like oh my God I can I
can I also enjoy being on camera more I
also enjoy making content more I I think
the the videos are better off for it
when I just embrace the fact that I'm
sometimes just I just do dumb stuff
I think that's and I think thats for the
show as well because like you know a lot
of people will watch that and being like
you know cuz like that's something you
would experience in your day-to-day life
with your friends right like sure you'll
have that like one super smart dude
who's always right about everything but
most of the time people are dumb as [__]
and they just make [__] up and that's
what's funny black black paint bro it's
just heavy it black paint until you
start talking about physics and stuff
then no my favorite is the polit not
Politics the um philos opy
Hees invented he invented philes
invented philosophy that was my favorite
yeah no my favorite one is the not my PR
moment I said that Pokemon was the most
Googled thing in 96 or something oh yeah
and it was just Google wasn't
made Google wasn't invented it was
2000 oh my God yeah I just I just want a
montage of like trash taste explains
stuff really [__] badly like like me
explaining the logarithmic scale or
whatever oh my God that was the one has
ever been a video that any of us have
done uh where you thought what a [__]
dumb idea when we you like got the video
and then you edited it and it turned out
like huh you can be honest this is like
I there's so many there's so many I can
say it out loud now finally yeah finally
I don't think that has been you just do
like normal stuff like even if it's like
very basic it can still be edited to be
a good video cuz like the the base
content around it is pretty decent mhm
so like even if you do like the most
basic things in Japan it's like fine
yeah yeah what about the dick Museum
like the oh that was great that was fun
I wish I could have used more it's kind
of [__] though cuz like yeah oh
everything needs to be censored actually
we can't show anything I sent him a
message being like so yeah I went to
this thing and I really want to include
in the YouTube video but you need to
Mosaic everything but me like like
onethird of the video was just sticks
everywhere on screen all time it's all
dicks and then I I cut it out initially
like Danny did and uh then he was like
no can I have some of it in yeah you got
include I was like you got to include
some of it this sh's wild and then to
actually show it it was just him and
kah's face unblurred everything else was
sensored Lally the entire frame well
that's like me when I went hentai
shopping right it was like it was I got
to one floor and I'm just like mud you
have to sense like [__] everything
why even do
this I think it's fun to see the the
just the sheer amount of [__] that needs
to be blured it kind of gives you a a
good perspective of like oh wow there is
just dicks everywhere exactly what do
you think of the modern Tik Tok style
editing or like you know the very
fastpaced very like you you literally
need to grab your attention every
microsc uh I like it but I don't like
shorts okay it's weird okay so I like
the Mr Beast the new Mr Beast style
editing where he actually tells a story
he like hits the emotional beats not
just like oh Tik Tok after Tik Tok in 10
minute like compation but I don't like
shorts themselves that are like 60
seconds cuz I don't know they're just
annoying to edit I I guess okay specific
shots are fine if you like Connor films
a specific uh video just for shots
that's great cuz that's like a 60c video
like specifically made for it that's
fine but if it's like a highlights video
that needs to be compiled Too Short
that's like that's what I make
you but it's so bizarre cuz sometimes I
I I don't understand what people want to
watch and why YouTube pushes understand
what they want to watch I still disagree
with shorts being a thing sorry I
disagree with shorts being a thing cuz
like you can get views from shorts you
can will get subscribers but you will
not get it will not translate into
long-term like views it doesn't
translate to an audience yeah I mean the
discussion is up in the air right now
I'm like on the fence about it but I
think like if you want to make your
short successful you need to make it
with making shorts in mind you can't
it's it's never like I know there's like
a million [__] podcast clip that gets
like repackaged to shorts but I don't
trash
taste you know hon Subway Surfer at the
bottom that's it is it is I find it from
my personal experience CU I get
recommended trash T Clips all the time
obviously I'm looking at it all the time
yeah I find it way easier to watch the
shorts than the clips yeah and I I will
admit that I think it's just a better
format for for short form Clips well
that's why every podcast now is doing
shorts right cuz I think they just
figured that out it's an easier way of
digesting uh digesting podcast I guess
it's like uh some sort of Banner
marketing cuz like when you have like
these banners pop up on YouTube it
doesn't want you actually click on it it
just wants you to recognize the name
like Coca-Cola you're not going to click
on it you're going to be like oh
Coca-Cola maybe I'll have it later and
that's the same with charts you'll be
like oh I've seen him couple times like
well you're that's what I'm think yeah
that's what I think it's more about just
I I I think that like getting just
getting eyes on it well yeah because
then people are going to keep if they
keep seeing you as a as a Creator or
something that's like the most important
thing because a lot of the time they
just need to recognize that that you're
someone that oh maybe I should watch
this guy yeah they'll be like who's this
guy I keep seeing this guy everywhere
yeah yeah yeah for sure um cuz you know
a lot of the times a lot of YouTubers
rely on sponsors and sponsors want
people uh or influencers uh with
recognizable faces or Brands right and
so having that kind of aware awareness
just it's not necessarily about does the
view translate to revenue or growth in
any capacity it's more like okay you
just need to become more your face needs
to be out there more right yeah I don't
know I weird weird weird it's a it's a
weird world now where you know it's
becoming more and more like I guess old
media and uh old like just marketing
tactics you know that's pretty much just
brand recognition just getting your face
out there smoking camel and malom
cigarettes we're bringing back the
asbesto cigarettes guys turns out it's
actually good for you I should do a
short where I just try every cigarette
and just see if they actually taste
different is it true though not
sponsored but sponsored by the malor
company is it true that coke actually
used to have cocaine in it or is that IM
yeah no it used to have Coke dude I wish
I could be boring we had in the in the
in the like I think it was the 50s or
60s I don't know which dat it was with
the asbestos thing that was that was
after Coke was in Coke we thought to put
asbestos in cigarettes cuz Coke was a
normal thing back in the day like people
would have it like oh you're you're like
sick yeah have some cocaine it was like
an ointment yeah yeah and then people
get like addicted to we were born in the
wrong
era you act like telling me I IL legally
I that was a joke are you telling me I
can get on the cheap well okay well true
true first of all must have been lit in
the 20s uh second of all it's not that
hard to believe cuz I mean look at
what's happened in America with the
opioid crisis right now it's obvious
that we haven't learned any lessons that
we're still going to prescribe and give
out stuff regardless of what effect we
we had the evidence now to know that it
would cause this and we still did it why
I don't [__] know we people will
continue to do it well big F of money uh
big F of money is powerful in America
this is this is like real [__] let's
turn into Joe
frog
game wouldn't be talking about big
farmer he's talking about which drug
would taste best anally or something you
know what I mean like I feel like this
is the first conversation people have
before like you you fast for 10 years
and like your flat Earth is
now this is where it all went this is
the conversation I started like you
can't trust any dude actually dude I
will fact check everything I'm going to
tell a story cuz there's no shot this
guy listens to this podcast and I'll
never find out who this is um I go to
this gym a lot and there's a coffee shop
that I like to go to all the time on the
way back um and I I go there and I've
seen this guy who looks like 50 or 60
years old I've seen him there maybe six
or seven times now I when I go in the
morning only in the early morning uh and
I've never spoken to him um and so this
time he came up to me and he spoke to me
uh and uh he goes hey man you live in
Japan I was like yeah man just I live
not too far from here uh and uh he's
like oh cool cool where are you from I
was like from Wales he's like Wales nice
place I used to live in China but I live
in Japan now I was like oh cool cool I
was like um where you from it's
California I was like oh I go to
California all the time I like it it's
great he's like well it's not as good as
it used to be and I was like oh okay
what do you mean by that he's like well
you know the Liberals kind of took over
and changed it I was like [__] head I
was like yeah yeah okay what do you what
you that's the moment where your brain
just instantly shots off I was like and
I I was like I was like okay well okay
sure man well yeah I mean he's like yeah
well I used to live in China but you
know the experiments with the bats and
all that I just didn't want to be there
anymore and I was like I was like okay
that's fine that's fine he's like and
then he I don't know how this even it
was even prompted he just goes oh yeah
you know I just I just think that uh I
just think that the president right now
by the way I voted for Obama he said
that as like a as a way to like I bear
in mind this whole time I've just been
nodding that's like the equivalent of I
have a black friend by the way but yeah
and he's like he's like I just think I
just think right now I just think think
that Trump will get it done and I was
like okay that's fine like I don't I
don't [__] care what you're political
leaning just don't do this to people why
are you opening up with this especially
when it's unprompted yeah I didn't ask I
didn't ask I don't care I do not care I
did not ask I am wait I'm literally just
praying that my coffee will be ready in
a moment so I can leave uh and of course
when I get my coffee he won't let me
leave he's just talking to me I like man
so who' you vote for I to stop him and
be like and yeah he goes on about brexit
and stuff and I was he's hitting all the
greatest hits I'm like leave me alone I
want to go yeah but um why why did I
bring this up again um I just want to
tell a story yeah I think this is just
cuz I met like a crazy person not a
crazy person but one of those people I
guess wait what the [__] were we saying
before this we were talking about uh
health benefits no we were that's way
far back no we're talking about like old
media coming back no no no no no we were
talking about we I theal risk is kicking
in% can I take a piss
sure well I trying to figure out what
the [__] we were talking about no we
were talking about [__] why did I bring
this up I had a good we shorts and then
we were talking about [__] Mudan bring
up the footage bring it up bring it up
oh [__] he's over there um there was a
reason why flat earthers that's it flat
earthers dude it's like you you will
just come across people no matter where
you are in the world and they will seem
totally chill and you let you let them
talk to you for 5 minutes and you'll
just realize the only thing that's
changed is that people who who we used
to consider like kind of out there are
like are so good
at being normal and just waiting for the
opportunity to say they're good at just
waiting like they know they okay not to
I I don't refer to them as crazy people
because I think that's unfair and that's
that's not that doesn't help situation
when you call them crazy but like people
with alternative beliefs are very good
now at knowing and they they try to sus
out people who they think will like not
reciprocate what and and I think because
I I think I attract these people um
because every Uber ride I will I will
never stop them from talking because I
just I'm so fascinated to hear I love
hearing every time I get in an Uber with
you I've never seen the Uber drive would
be that chatty well cuz I'll prompt them
and they're not and they're not talking
to me cuz I got my headphones well cuz I
prompt them like we had that guy in
Florida one time I was about to say the
Florida guy it was this of course it was
a Florida guy but it was a Ukrainian guy
uh who was in Florida I was saying how I
I I attract I'm I'm I can sus out when
people are going to say these weird
stuff and I
always what're because I think that like
to how these people I need to like where
they coming from and so I'm always just
kind of like yeah yeah maybe you're
right I just say stuff like that and
then just kind of prod them and keep
telling them and this yeah guy in
Florida
who he was insane he yeah he bro he'd
been he'd been he'd been uh he'd been
watching the lot of news uh he been had
strong opinions about Trump watching a
lot of fox yeah a lot of fox opinions
very interesting very interesting I mean
sometimes you talk to someone and like I
have you ever had a point where you've
talked to someone and you know it's kind
of like you hear a line and you're like
oh yeah I know immediately and you're
like you definitely you definitely heard
this from a podcast or something this
you definitely been on Reddit a bit too
long well it's because they they
generally people who with these types of
beliefs will say one line that is very
like uh um non-committal to their
opinion and they'll see how you react to
it but it's so easy to Su out when
they're doing this like I voted for
Obama by the way well well like when he
said like well when he said like uh like
California is not as good as it used to
be yeah like that's just such a like
subtle way of like trying to sus out why
you stand on it that's when you hear the
vsource music you know he's about to go
off about something I'll be like oh man
how so yeah and then and then he'll say
this crazy thing oh I guess I say crazy
to me I mean some of it is just insane
but sometimes he'll say something and
I'm like man yeah I guess I got
something to think about yeah I'm going
to go home like [__] never talk that guy
again Jesus Christ yeah like I I think I
had like the exact same moment at a
party I was at like when I was when I
was in America uh in the midwest by the
way that's oh bro for oh oh of course uh
yeah so you know I was I was at this uh
random I was at this random party uh
that you know had a bunch of like you
know it's you know when you're at a
party and you get invited because a guy
knows a guy and uh you know you you're
invited there but you don't really know
anyone there so my least favorite kind
of parties so you know I was there
because some of uh some of like uh
Sydney's Brothers old friends were there
but you know it was kind of like a
[__] massive party you so they didn't
know everyone there uh so I was just
kind of like susing out the vibe of some
people and the thing about America I've
I've I've like noticed is that you go to
a party and sometimes you do not know
what kind of like the vibe or the people
you're surrounded with are going to be
like you know um and so you know you I
was I was talking to this random guy and
I can't remember we got on the topic of
like relationships uh just cuz I
mentioned I was married and stuff like
that and he was like oh how how is that
going you are you happily married I'm
like yeah and I just asked are you like
in a relationship or anything like that
and he's like no no I'm I'm I'm saving
myself and so I was like oh so I assumed
it must be like a religious thing right
and then uh he I was like and this was
the line where he was like no I've been
uh I've been waiting for a virgin
because you know I think
that was he an idol fan no no I I think
that just virgins are the way to go I
think once you lose your virginity the
woman just become lower value and I'm
like this is this is a [__] Andrew
Tate listener like I I it was the first
how do you respond to
that yeah how do I respond I was like oh
cool good luck this is the exact kind of
person I'd love to talk talk to I would
love I would love to be like just just
tell me more about it what do you think
about that you know some people might
say that that's a that's a bigoted way
of looking at it why what do you think
about
that oh cuz like I you know talking to
the guy he's exactly the type of guy he
was like as much of like a typical frat
boy as you could like imagine like kind
like that kind of like image uh it was
just the first time that i' had so
obviously met someone who had been
influenced by let's say the podcast
era of things where where you you hear
verbatim a line that you've heard on
some random Tik Tok that has been
recommended for you yeah you know cuz a
lot of these guys are just they're just
like hey my life's not going the way I
wanted it to this guy just told me that
it's all women's fault and now I guess
that that's how I'm going to live my
life and that's just my belief now
what's it like in Estonia huh is it fun
in Estonia making friends talking to
people crazy people we don't talk to
anybody it's like the north you go up
there the less people talk to yeah like
if you're in your America people talk to
you on a bus in uh like northern Europe
you'll get sh
shanked like hi there like don't talk to
random people it's weird like they'll
instantly think you'll like crazy or
something yeah that does happen and I
think it's a very British as well do not
just approach people in public that is
just a big no no yeah for sure do you
think the average trash taste listener
instead of like quoting some very
opinionated political opinion just just
starts quoting like shitty food takes is
that how you tell like a trash it
happens they just be at a party and
they'll be like actually I hate Crossing
all pizza by the way and then be like oh
God which podcast did you hear that
for d i I've been to ax people randomly
come up like oh hey Muran they just
randomly start talking about the food
takes yeah like wait what do they say
well no I like oh I like uh the boneless
chicken or I like bone in or stuff like
that like I didn't ask yeah all right
that's that's great for you yeah sick
Bro oh you don't like bread as well all
right sick no you you only eat bread and
pasta and rice yeah yeah well I don't
care I eat everything e you just said
you just eat rice and just past it no
that was like like [__] seven years
ago what do you now everything you like
everything what's what's your favorite
cyanide I
wish no I I guess I've uh become more
like you where it's like Uber Eats is
cheaper uh to be more productive like
making food the amount it takes like you
go to the store you buy it and you make
I'm not lazy mhm well Japan is so cheap
no wonder you [__] get everything I I
I try to tell people this dude when I
when you UBS in America right it's
ridiculous you you you will order a
lunch it'll be like $15 by the time you
get it you've paid $35 somehow yeah yeah
[__] shipping here 50 cents to have
like all breeds here yeah you and often
the restaurants don't mark up so a lot
of the times you'll just pay the normal
amount I have no idea who's making money
someone's losing money in this thing the
overall food here is like half the price
as in Europe pretty much yeah most of my
Uber eat meals come to around $10 which
is what I would pay if I went out and
just like got it anyway exactly so for
me it's like it I mean it sounds lazy
and I I absolutely is but I love it and
the fact that I can pay $10 and get a
meal delivered to my door that good and
and healthy and great quality is like
this is [__] the UK could never the UK
absolutely could never most countries
could never uh
yeah I'm very lazy yes and I mean
Japan's always been cheaper to eat out
anyway you know yeah M so you know that
that image of like the soldiers holding
up the world and there like a mom and a
kid there literally the Uber delivery
drivers in Japan they holding up Japan
right now they they are holding up this
economy dead us no it's like them and
like I heard there's like a shortage of
like Japanese bus drival or something
that I don't know if this is yeah
there's a rout in chba that used to run
60 times a day and now it's down to
seven you have bosses yeah we have B but
there's also like also taxi drivers uh
and Kyoto have gone down I think 25%
this year and they need more D um so
yeah there but they've started hiring
some taxi films stting hiring foreign
taxi drivers oh really I'm just going to
say it all right I don't think I don't
think that the the this quality uh of
Japanese taxi driver is that good that
only Japanese taxi drivers can do the
job of course it's not like in London
where they're trained to like they have
to learn every single Street in Japan
you're like hey can I go here and he's
like what is Tokyo Station well half the
time they just like oh okay I don't know
where that is use the GPS all of them
use the GPS and also I would prefer them
to use the GPS cuz a lot of the times
when they I think 50 I don't know not
50% like there's a good chance if they
go by memory that they [__] it up oh
yeah so I'm just like can you I always
ask them to use the GPS uh cuz I'm like
just please please go here please yeah I
always just tell them put in this
address yeah so I feel like there's no
there's no need for them to get qy about
it just let the let the let the let's
Steve from Wisconsin Drive the cabs I'll
I'll I'll do it what's what's been your
favorite thing about Japan so far
favorite thing here yeah like how's your
experience been here this is your first
time damn I'm not sure I mean you only
know about it for trash days apparently
yeah pretty much I was not expecting to
weather but this hot but other than that
you really oversold the comis like for
the first four days I was so
disappointed in comis why I don't know I
was expecting something like magical
what the [__] are you talking they do do
everything what do name one thing they
don't do uh gluten-free food oh come on
that's what do you what do you want them
to do it's h right no no no I'm I'm
coming around to them like now I start
to like them again you just I feel like
you just hyped them up so much they are
so good well how are the convenience
stores in Estonia I don't know it it
feels the same like oh you go to cast
station you get like uh fresh food
that's like hot and you have everything
you need just we don't have this in
either of any of our countries or
Thailand maybe you know have a Circle K
what the [__] is a Circle K never mind I
know Circle K but we we don't have it
it's getting better in our countries I
think but uh UK is definitely getting
better but yeah UK the food quality in
the UK is definitely going up oh my God
from being from when I was a kid it's
gone up so much it's so weird now every
time I go back to the UK and I'm like
I'm excited to go to restaurants and eat
and before I was just like my God every
Google review is just lying to me gre
gre gre oh Greg Greg's is good did you
have Gregs in the UK uh never [__] did
you have you have a meal deal though
right I don't know no you had a meal
deal from Tesco have I yeah you told me
you had one did I I I maybe lied what
the [__] Li I have no idea what you're
talking about
you get the sandwich and you get a bag
of crisps and you get a drink oh then no
what maybe you talked to somebody else
no you said you did you looked me in the
eye no I did
not going have the window off
correction I have no idea what you're
talking
about I don't think I've had a Tesco's
meal deal all right next time we're in
the UK we have you at least had anando
right yeah yeah he was you were there
when he had
nandos God damn it the DI is really
kicking in we've had Nando I'm pretty
sure we have yeah we had it like yeah
yeah not this year yeah we did not this
year I can't remember this year we I
just remember because we went to the
restaurant and you said wow are the
chicken thighs really that calic two of
us like with Emily andus not with oh
yeah I was like are you gaslighting me
are we were there no I'm being Gastly
I'm like wait I have I had done okay
here's the problem I've had Nano so many
times in my last trip to UK that I
literally can't remember everyone I've
been to Nan second meal was anando it's
[__] up that the spicier the sauce the
more calories it has I feel I feel like
that's [__] up is that true yeahand
the more spicy the sauce the more
calories it has I don't know why maybe
CU they have to compensate to make more
flavor is chilies that much calories no
but I think they adding other stuff to
like help because obviously like
thickeners yeah I think that normal hot
sauce is just too like one noted so you
have to add a lot of other super spicy
like sauce is kind of the consistency of
elma's glue like let goated I love that
[__] insane [__] I miss Nando already as
[__] how do you feel Nando compared to
Australian nandos have you been to
Australian nandos yeah once and then it
went out of business cuz it was [__] I
heard the same thing happened in Canada
as well yeah okay so what's the your
favorite thing in Japan so far you
didn't answer not the com you comedies
weren't your favorite thing fine you're
dead to me but it's fine no I said I'm
coming around to them I like them now
okay what's what's the one thing that
actually lived up to the hype in Japan
is there anything uh they're aesthetic
like everything I I would say just
coming to Japan everything is as like
anime or aesthetic as you expect it's
like the vibe right it is the vibe is
correct the vibe is
correct the vibe
check I was here I was like yeah I could
see myself living here it's like really
nice yeah like the weather is nice
people nice you think they'd be like oh
no gin no no but everybody's been like
really nice even if they can't speak
they like try and like I haven't been
rejected once it's really cool well you
haven't I don't think you've been to
like the the old like M and pop shops
those are those are usually the places
where they just like oh no foreigners
but like a standard restaurant now it's
like they're not going to deny you just
cuz you're a foreigner nowadays like
Pete took me out for like a Premiere 2
uh for like a night out with at bars and
all the bars were just so great yeah the
bars are fantastic the bars are the one
thing that do not disappoint in Japan
yeah yeah it was literally like
everything you'd expect yeah totally
yeah honestly like I every time I go to
a bar in Japan it it makes the rest of
the world just feel so much more
disappointing in terms of like the vibe
it's always a good it's just crazy like
the quality the cost you pay like yeah a
[__] yeah and just like the amount of
choice there is is just goated bro and
and bars just like it's great little
snacks they give you I love little
snacks yeah hell yeah you know like you
know obviously I have to
like as a British I have to say of
course we have like comp comparing
weather spoons to some of the [__] PS
with the boys the [__] pups let's go
but yeah Japanese bars are absolutely
[__] goed mhm I do like pops though
but they feel different in my mind like
a bar is in two different like the bars
in Japan is where I go to like I'm like
man let's let's just like deep talk I
have the counter the music the nice
cocktails with the guy the guy spends
like 15 hours making it yeah he puts
like the ice cubes that have been like
finally crafted with the Damascus steel
blade and the ice from Hokkaido for some
reason you're like okay cool he's like
it's a gent
tonic it's also but he spent $15 no it's
like no actually no it's like uh they're
like like 10 bucks 10 bucks I think so
yeah yeah I think it was yeah roughly
unless it's like a highend you're
talking about European prices dude
European cocktail prices are Next Level
yeah you think America's expensive
European cocktails are like 155 for a
cocktail which is like $20 you treated
me out to like cocktails and were like
oh when it com to St I'll pay you back
but it's like three times as much to pay
you well well I told him I was like he
want going to pay it I was like no no
don't I'm paying and then I was like
just just pay pay for me when I come to
Estonia and he was like no no that's
Estonia is more expensive I was like ah
well the end's really weak right now so
do you know do you know the biggest
discrepancy I've noticed between you
know the meme which is just like thing
thing in Japan yeah it's
like get recommended like any like Tik
Tok or YouTube short where it's just
like a very very expensive product from
a very specialist guy that's been honing
their craft uh and if it's like a
western person doing it half the
comments are like this is [__]
expensive why why why the [__] would I
why who cares if it's handmade or not
but Jaan Tanaka Yoshimi spent 60 years
crafting this table and all the comments
are just like oh my God that's
dedication such a master to the craft oh
dedication I thank you Sensei I remember
I saw this like I remember I saw this uh
short about I think it was like a
Japanese Craftsman who had made like the
calligraphy brushes and he like makes it
by hand oh yes I've seen that and I'm
like it was ridiculously expensive and
he goes like basically he puts in the
individual by
and and I'm just like I mean I get it
but it's a bit much is
it ha I mean I get I I admire the
dedication but would I pay a grand for
it yeah yeah not sure you know when
you're young and you just like drink
anything just because it serves the
purpose of getting you drunk and the
most important thing was how efficiently
how cost effective could you get drunk
the vodka Red Bulls the vodka Red Bulls
oh man you should eat the one chip okay
no don't do I will die no you would you
would actually they' removed it for
health concern yeah we still have it
yeah look we we have it for some reason
like a kid died yeah someone died from
it was [__] I had it and I I can
handle spice but it was [__] no I had
uh two of my editors who are like help
with a stream eat it uh both of them
puked and the day was ruined oh my day
was ruined after it too it was it was
very very painful yeah good um but I
guess my stomach's used to it now I had
is used to it now I think so yeah does
it want to be used to it maybe not I
don't know I had a bunch of hot sauces
that expired today this morning so I had
to pour them all out cuz I had to clean
the bottles to recycle the bottles uhhuh
and so I I was getting rid of all the
hot sauce and it made the air spicy cuz
I was emptying all the bottles and I was
breathing and it was it was making my
throat itch oh [__] everywhere in my
house it was [__] God damn so so uh be
careful yeah that's it fun
story I think uh my so I went back home
this time and every time I go home now
I've noticed my mom makes like I there
was a point in my childhood where I was
in AED how spicy my mom could eat like
spicy food and then I got to a point
where I started liking spicy food and I
think I progressively liked more and
more spicy food as I go as I go older um
so every time I come home now I've
noticed she always makes it a little bit
more spicy gear spicy just just a little
bit more spicy like limit testing me and
uh same thing with Sydney and every time
she uh every time she feeds us food now
every time we like just cough a little
bit she's like it's too spicy too spicy
it's a little bit too spicy sometimes
just hits your throat the wrong way it
could be fine but you just you know what
I mean like come on totally yeah the hot
ones ruin me you you did the hot ones
one time right yeah cuz I used to have
like uh take normal Tabasco sauce and
that was my limit but then I did hot
ones uh well I cried a couple times but
afterwards I Tobasco is just so simple
yeah Tobasco is just a little like
little yeah I used to think the same
like when I used to handle like no spice
I was like oh Tobasco is too spicy but
then I had like several levels above and
now I [__] love to Basco on
everything what level did you get when
you got nandos that's that's that's like
medium or high you got
herb no you got garlic and
herb the sauce I put later on that was
uh oh oh oh yeah me later on but you
chose garlic and herb andish yeah I
remember cuz I was disappointed in you
but I put the sauce on later I'm kidding
I'm kidding I'm just [__] with you oh
yeah yeah yeah cuz you can't handle
spicy food I I remember now yeah you
can't handle spicy food at all I
remember we went to Chipotle in America
and you were like you were like how can
you eat this I was like it has jalapenos
in it just because of that they also
gave you like a kilogram and the burrito
was 1 kilo it's like what I eat in two
days that's messed up it's like 1,500
calories you cannot fit it in your mouth
you literally can well yeah you bite
edges you bom bom bom this this is the
true test to see if you have truly
become parasocial listening to too much
trash taste what's your opinion of
America when you went for LA or like
You' been a few times now right to
preface I've only been to
LA Downtown LA to be specific it's the
only place in America you've been right
yes uh Two Times by now it's
bad well obviously downtown LA is bad
I think even everyone in La will be like
downtown is awful yeah a third world
country
yeah having this yeah that's fair enough
don't cut that don't cut that M leave it
in but uh yeah cuz you've been to like
you normally go for ax every year right
yeah I try
to CU like I can't what was the first ax
you went to cuz that was definitely
before you started working for us yeah
it was it must have been yeah was
definitely before Co right 2018 I think
or 2019 something like that that's where
I met you for the time where you helped
Connor film a video or something like
that where he went to a date with a fan
oh yeah yeah I did do that yeah yeah oh
yeah you did too yeah cuz a fan asked to
have a date it wasn't really a date it
was just film but yeah a fan asked to
have a date and I thought well [__] it
let's see how it goes then can I
recorded them yeah it was it wasn't like
a real day but it was fun uh it was it
was a funny video yeah I remember that
yeah cuz we stayed at uh my my previous
editor's house and it was it was it was
rough what's what's your favorite
country you have visited then o that's
hard I would say maybe Amsterdam cuz
that's really nice like the whole city
is so walkable City but all right oh
well yeah the entire place it's pretty
nice yeah what do you mean I country
said country [__] uh well I haven't
walkable no it is walkable but it's like
when I went from LA to Amsterdam was
such a huge difference like we would
walk for like an hour on foot and it was
like nothing it's was like oh that's so
nice you just you just describe you just
describe walkable there's no homeless
people fighting are up there nobody
threatening there's a reason why La is
not a walkable City you know no even out
of Europe I I would say it's one of the
better ones maybe like if you're not in
the very center cuz I've been to yeah
most of them like I I don't see what
what the hate about Paris is I like
Paris really really well I've lived in
Paris what the [__] when did you live in
Paris uh I worked there for like two
summers we doing what uh
Disneyland oh yeah you did tell me this
year oh yeah [__] Disneyland at
Disneyland in Paris and you ended up not
hating the city no I'm very surprised I
lived in a ghetto like outside of on the
outskirts of Paris and Disneyland is
like even further out it's like Paris is
like hanada to Tokyo oh Nar Nar Nar so
like Disneyland is fun and uh Paris
itself cuz if you go as a tourist it's
can be cool also I knew how to speak
French so I went everywhere can you
still speak French uh I can like enough
oh wow but not perfectly okay so like I
went to everywhere like trying to speak
French but if you start out in English
then you're not going to have a good
time yeah I think that's a big
difference you know just got to show
that you're not English that's the first
step if they get through that then
you're I that's pretty why I I didn't
like it as much I'm like man everyone
[__] sucks
here so yeah I mean that that is the big
Paris saac if you even speak a little
bit of English damn yeah you've had a
crazy life huh Paris and obviously
before you did uh you were editing you
did um softcore uh porn is in the chest
piece obviously um this is my favorite
story you've ever told me you have to
tell G the story we're far we're far
enough in the episode now where it's f
yeah so uh at the beginning I was
picking up every job like that I could
because I I it was so hard to do
anything as an editor like I I would say
I'm like the second wave of editors
where pretty much editing for YouTubers
didn't exist back then so it was like
really hard to find one and I was using
this site called upwork which was like a
decent back then but now it's really
[__] cuz uh you have to pay for every
review you send in back then I used to
send in like 60 reviews every single day
or something like that uh and one of the
jobs I got was like oh uh do you want to
edit vlog Vlogs and I'm like all right
cool uh and I started editing it I'm
like yeah that's a bit um that this is a
bit weird and I guess I edited it well
enough that he he was like um well do
you want to do more stuff and I was like
okay what was this initial Vlog what
was [__] I can't remember it was
something about um pleasuring
women so I was like I was kind of
picking up like all right was a guy
talking about it yeah like how to place
your women something like that but but I
think there was a bit more Lish type
thing right hey guys I'm going to
pleasure a woman like follow my way to
pleasure women like what the [__] yeah
so then he was like okay do you want to
edit more like more raunchier stuff I'm
like all right you know sure whatever
pays the bills man yeah exactly and yeah
just softcore porn is it what is
softcore porn what does that involv like
just no penetration like kissing uh well
he had a niche of course you have a
niche which is is uh Yoni massage okay
which is uh [__]
massage so he would he would be like
expertise cats right like like cat
massage yeah it would be him doing it
for around 2 to three hours what okay
two it would go up to five I think no
and uh actually it was a nice precursor
to trash taste
cuz now there are three [__] screen
cuz he he had had uh like four to five
camera setup okay and uh gar you say
you're a perfectionist yeah but he was
an actual perfectionist it would be like
2 to three hour video like end result
where it had to be like the cuts had to
be frame perfect it would if it would be
like one frame off it would be like on
me like I had to change it right and uh
every Friday we would get in calls uh
that would last like 4 to 6 hours of
just trying going through the edits like
oh the intro that's like not that good
or I have to change that
s cut be FR like um when I started it
was like two ofation how to cut it like
in the beginning it would be like
YouTubers do now which would be like
fast-paced like intro that was like s
years ago at this point yeah and then it
would be a music video
section of what of a like getting into
it undressing like what the heck stuff
and then it would be like slowly getting
into the main section of like actually
doing it which was um
there's also rules behind it like uh in
the beginning it would be Cuts Like
every 10 SEC uh seconds if you're like
half an hour in it could be like up to
30 seconds a cut it can't be over 30
seconds and the cut has to be at the
apex of the
movement the apex of the
movement why is he talking like a movie
director it was it was actually that
intense Jesus but yeah it lasted for
like 2 years did he pay well uh okay H
and then he was like okay you know I'm
I'm paying you too much I'm going to
replace you with two cheap uh people
instead and you know that's when we gave
you the call for trash taste right no
okay so I used to like I I like to go
back and like check on like PE previous
employers like how they're doing yeah
for the next year he posted nothing and
then approached me and was like all
right I'm going to offer you double the
price you paid I'm like guess those two
editors weren't that good and I'm like
was he making a lot of money from this
or I assume so wow cuz it's Poland and I
was like I don't I don't know how much
money I was like uh no I want to get
paid three times as much cuz I'm like no
and he was like No And I was like yeah
and he was like okay and then you went
back you got back in it yeah how many
years ago was this uh originally like 5
years ago I at it for two years then it
was like a break of one year and then
for another two years and it was even
more intense cuz at the end I I gave up
I was like okay I can't do it I'm
quitting cuz it was so intense like uh
the work sessions was so huge it was
literally like uh 20 hours a week that
was half that was a part-time job next
to like six YouTubers I also edited for
wait were you doing this while you were
editing for me
yeah and con wow wow I didn't know this
and uh I think yeah when I quit uh I I
gave in like my two months notice yeah
which I figured out I found out you
don't have to give two months notice
yeah you can just leave yeah I didn't
know that I was like I I don't want to
be a dick like leaveing me I it's polite
to give me it's but usually it's one
month
notice yeah a lot a lot of contract one
month so we started writing up like what
to give to the next person like they had
to do the same thing cuz to get every
like video done it wasn't just the main
video it was also like different
websites different timestamps different
every so it was kind of like gaming the
system cuz the thumbnails in those sites
were autogenerated based on what it
picks up at those time like seconds like
frames but he had a system where he knew
if the videos was this long it would
generate these frames right like for
every website it had to be a different
length video and so he planned out like
where exactly the frames would be oh my
God and it was like four different
Google Sheets to actually get like one
video done and when we tried to get like
new people in to like replace me I think
the end result for the Google docs on
how you edit a video was 40
pages how do you write 40 pages it was
so in that's why I wanted to finish cuz
it wasn't fun it wasn't editing it was
literal job like had to do everything
wanted to as well yeah and it was 4
years and even at the end of four years
I still felt like I couldn't do it like
how he wanted to yeah like I was you
were imperfect enough for him yeah I was
so imperfect it was so annoying to me as
well cuz I like couldn't so how many
hours of this cat massaging did you have
to sit through like in total yeah like
per session or like you must be so
desensitized yeah you must be so
desensitized to it I think at the end it
was my 500s I don't
know
Christ it's so funny holy [__] oh my
Lord and now he's on trash T so honestly
it was a bit sketchy cuz it was a huge
chunk of Revenue but when you were like
trash tasted I was like okay this is a
good chance like move
past to move
F I could use all my skills correctly
maybe get some free time you know but
that was the last thing that also like
really burned me out like in terms of
editing well you get yeah that's yeah
let me ask you this question how do you
avoid burnout in your in your uh like
the way you think the way you do things
I don't I it's either I I just don't
like I either got burned out 6 years ago
or I don't I don't know where do you
just I just don't get burned out do you
just not recognize the burnout and you
just kind of push through it all I think
I'm desensitized to burnout or I just
take jobs that like don't burn me out
cuz like there's so much work that I
have to do that anytime I get like tired
of one job I like switch over to oh I'm
make thumbnails now or I'm going to do
clips now I'm going to go back to the
first job I'm going to do like a
different different thing so I guess
having like a variation of different
jobs is like a good way right yeah yeah
yeah cuz burnout is just suboptimal
performance you know [__] you're right I
got to start taking my vitamins burnout
just like a skill issue at the end of
the day you know not managing Rabbit
Hole to go down the moment I feel burned
out I just pop open that medicine box
I'm good to go one thing you also told
me that I just didn't appreciate because
I'm like man we're so fortunate have to
do this that you did uh in in Estonia
you have to do uh mandatory Service as
well yeah so you to do like 8 months of
military time right yeah oh really After
High School I went into like straight
away cuz I didn't want to do it later
cuz if they call you like 5 years down
the line when you're doing [__] yeah
yeah it really sucks so I had to I went
there like uh voluntarily they were like
no you're too skinny come back in half a
year like no no no let's do two month uh
weeks and they were like all right one
month so I went back and thankfully got
it cuz otherwise it would have gone like
another year yeah yeah and yeah then I
got in and what if you were too skinny
the entire time could they just could
they just never ask you to serve yeah
but I don't think I would have been cuz
before that I had like some sort of a
disease that lasted for a month that I
couldn't eat so I lost 10 kg in weight
damn okay wow so I was like yeah I can
easily pack that on like get me in two
weeks and I'll do
it what did you do for those two weeks
just [__] go to town I just ate
normally cuz I ate normally for like a
month I could only eat once a day and it
was like one pudding otherwise it would
have been too painful right oh my God
what disease is that I think I had I'm
not sure if it was mono like like my uh
the the glands yeah that's mono right
those like really went insanely huge and
got like infected so I had to take like
not Paras like insane painkillers that
you can take once a day and then even
then I could just eat pudding otherwise
it's like too
much Christ is there any part of your
life that you can you still think you
can optimize or find time next for
what's next for mud it's just well it's
not like huge optimization movements
it's just like slow like steady
like you get a new client you're like
all right how can I got to ask what's
what's an average day look like for you
wake up uh see around 9 a.m. nice oh I
see what you guys have written like uh
the fires I have to take out cuz usually
when I wake up in the morning it's
around like noon or night time for you
and then I'm like oh my God there's like
10 things that popped up I got to do ads
got to do that so the first 2 3 hours of
just doing like origin stuff yeah then I
eat then I do um either gym or U running
cardio and then I do like the stuff that
I had to do that day like 10 20 items I
usually put in my to-do list yeah that's
a
lot that comes you make it sound easy
that comes after the gym and everything
like that doing 10 20 things in a day or
I guess more realistically the second
half of the day is quite a bit uh and
then it's like 2: a.m. and I go to bed
do you ever do you ever get cuz like
I've had you know weeks when I've been
super super productive and all it takes
is like one little slip off to take you
off your like schedule and routine and
then everything like just crumbles doe
do you ever get that all or oh yeah it
does happen like after vacations and
stuff no well no you work on
vacations what no every okay I get it I
never fall out of working the only thing
I fall out of is just like taking care
of myself right diet or gym as I'll
slack and I'll be like okay I'll slack
another day like out of five years or
six years of doing this I think Japan
was the first time like this is the most
I've taken off or like away from my uh
home like ever this is 2 weeks usually
it's like 3 days oh really or 3 4 days
yeah yeah so I mean even here like every
day four or five hours of work oh my God
please please get please have a vacation
please have a day where you do nothing
day you just try why do you refuse
sounds awful I did the white room stream
I didn't feel that great like that at
all I did nothing fors [__] vacation
you actually doing stuff m i I didn't do
anything I took 12 hours off it wasn't
that fun I we a white room what do you
expect I took 12 hours off here's what
happened guys Chris be like I took 36
years off of my life I saw I saw I saw a
[__] screenshot and it was like from
Tik Tok and it was a guy going like and
it was like unemployed people when they
have to eat breakfast and play video
games all day
that's like rud
no just try it you can you can turn into
a YouTube video if I Haven tried it I
don't like it I took a day off level
impossible it's horrible now I get the
Jitters I'm like [__] I got to edit man
[__] give it to me enough where is
the timeline godam it uh any advice you
might have uh for editors yeah or future
editors no like if you don't like it
quit I mean I think that's great advice
that's just great life advice in general
do you do you like editing or do you
want to get lots of YouTube views which
is
it damn tell them tell them how it is B
but yeah um thanks for coming coming on
finally yeah finally we got you on after
170 something episode yeah thanks for
having me absolutely pleasure the
machine on that uh the man the myth the
legend the man the myth the legend is
there anything you want to shout out by
the way uh no no go check out his no go
check out his streams he's a great
streamer Channel mud on YouTube I post
once or twice a month and I just they're
great videos no they're great videos
yeah hey look at all these patrons
though you
see he knows never do like the edges
they always go in the middle this
guy he know in his mind he knows exactly
where the frame is it's like it ends
right there he always gets looked over
him this guy right here is a real one
but hey if you'd like to be pointed at
Mudan or a future guest or one of us
then consider joining us on patreon
patreon.com trashtaste also follow us on
Twitter send memes on the subred and if
you ha a face listen to us on Spotify
and of course go check out M on the goat
we wouldn't be here 170 something an
anime YouTube would probably not be here
not for him it's just like all of like
adime YouTube and like Mudan in like
[__] Atlas just holding the Glo in
like 2018 or whatever I can't remember
how long it's
been hell yeah but um thanks for coming
on M on and we'll see you guys next week
bye
[Music]
wow